what's that I don't see anything moral
about where she is I know Bruce said he
was
coming weather is New
England
okay folks uh going to give it about
another five minutes and we'll get going
here
okay folks we're going to get going here
executive session uh have a numerous
bills today to exec so we'll get going
on that uh before we do uh why don't
why doesn't the clerk lead us in the
pledge this morning
please okay thank you Mr Clerk and when
you are ready we can do the roll call
please
Vice chairman power here represent
Guffy clerk is here representative lales
here representative yella present uh
representative
Nadia
here uh representative Elwood president
representative Brown here representative
kill here representative
stavis here
representative
syes here representative
Gilman here representative majori here
representative
Gallagher representative Hicks here
representative Howland here
representative priest here
representative FR here and here chairman
tart
pres thank you Mr clerk uh just like to
let everybody know we do have two
individuals sitting in in uh replacement
today representative Sykes uh and
representative nder joins
us
welcome okay we'll go ahead and open up
the executive session on one HB 1034
relative to enabling municipalities to
adopt a homestead property tax exemption
I believe representative stavis has a
motion thank you Mr Mr chair I'd like to
move interim study on this bill is there
a second on that representative priest
moves uh the second on
that does anybody have any
discussion seeing absolutely none we
will ask the clerk to call a
rooll vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie yes clerk
votes yes representative sales yes
represent yella
no uh represent n
yes representative Elward
yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
stavis
yes representative Sykes yes yes
representative Gilman yes represent
Maori
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes uh
representative FR yes and Mr chairman
yes uh motion passes 17 to one thank you
Mr Clark uh representative stavis I
assume you will write the blurb on that
one I will Mr sure thank you uh any
objections to go on
consent seeing none it'll go on the
consent calendar that uh closes the
exact session on HB
1034 all right we'll open up the exact
on HB
1154 and I looks like representative
power has a motion thank you Mr chairman
um I would like to offer amend amendment
2024-25
is there a second on that
Amendment I'll second that Mr chairman
thank you representative Brown seconds
the motion on the
amendment am sure it is uh
0198 H
right
y okay so representative power would
like to speak to your Amendment yes um
thank you Mr chairman so this amendment
um simply just changes one um thing and
that's on lines 13 and
14 I um swapped out previous wording and
um replaced it with the words as defined
in RSA 72 colon 29 Roman numeral V and
that this just makes this the statute if
it gets signed into law more clear as
this citation refers to the definition
of surviving
spouse thank you representative do we
have any discussion on the
amendment
see none Mr chairman representative
lales yes um I'm not sure of the of the
proper time to do this but um there is a
possibility down the road that I could
benefit from this bill and this
amendment um I fit the qualifications
for permanently and totally disabled
veteran as a result of my service I
follow this Chariot around and my wife
and I live in a home that was built in
1771 there is a
time uh that in order to stay in that
home that we are going to have to modify
it so that I can survive in that home so
I reached out to the chairman and to the
ethics people um and they they said that
I don't have to knock myself out of
consideration on this bill but I do need
to disclose it and so that's what I'm
doing thank you representative lales I
will consider that as being
disclosed and uh seeing no more comments
we'll ask that the clerk call a rooll on
the
amendment
okay amendment number 0198
H Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guffy cliar votes yes
represent sales yes representative
Keller yes uh representative n yes
representative Elwood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis
yes uh representative syes yes yes
representative Gilman yes represent
Maori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes uh
representative frch yes and Mr chairman
yes motion passes 19 to zero thank you
Mr clerk representative power do you
have another
motion thank you Mr chair I would like
to to make a motion ought to pass as
Amendment as amended on House Bill
1154 do we have a second on
that um representative priest second
that thank you representative any
discussion seeing none when the clerk is
ready if you could call the role
please
okay uh 1154 a to passes
amended Vice chairman power yes
representative guthy collect votes yes
representative lales yes representative
y Kella yes represent n yes
representative Ood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes uh
representative Sykes yes representative
Gilman yes representative majori yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes uh
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
French yes and Mr chairman yes uh motion
pass is 19 to zero thank you Mr clerk
uh representative power I assume you
will do the
lb and unless there's any objection this
will go on the consent
calendar seeing no objections it will go
on
consent and that closes the exact on
1154 okay uh next up HB 1258 relative to
a waiver from property taxes for
disabled veterans open up the EXA
session on on that I believe we have a
motion from representative
Brown yes Mr chairman I'd like to itl
this bill do we have a second on that
yes I'll second that motion
representative kahill seconds that is
there any discussion on that bill
representative lales my previous
disclosure applies to this bill also
accepted
okay seeing no more uh discussion we'll
ask when the clerk is we're going fast
aren't we sorry when you're ready we
will take the vote on
that okay uh itl on
1258 representative Vice chairman power
I'm sorry yes representative Guthrie
clerk votes yes representative Salis yes
representative Keller yes um represent n
yes representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kill yes representative Davis
no representative
Sykes
no representative Gilman no
representative majority
no
no excuse me representative gallager uh
no representative Hicks
no representative Howen no
representative priest no uh
Representative frch
no and Mr chairman
yes uh motion passes 10 to
n thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Brown I assume you will
be writing the blurb for that yes I will
Mr chairman thank you and who on the
Democrat side would like to write the
blurb for The Minority Report
yeah
I it's not going to go on cons well is
there objection to the consent
calendar
I think they're
confused okay let's let's back up
representative power go ahead thank you
Mr chairman um it appears to me as
though um there's some confusion as to
what we're voting on and what Bill we're
on so I would respectfully request that
maybe we slow down the pace a little bit
so that people can get organized and and
understand where we are I I'm having a
little bit of trouble myself thank you
very good we are currently on HB
1258 or are we on
1086 1258 right8 1258
so there seem to
be the possibility of a confusion on
the all right let's just take two two
minutes
here okay so there appears to have been
some confusion on that vote
so I believe there's nothing that
prevents us from going back and taking a
revote on that motion to reconsider
motion to reconsider second
representative sis second all
uh all those in favor of
reconsider say I I all those against
okay the motion carries
unanimously and now we will reconsider
and revote when
the clerk is Comfortably
ready uh go ahead remake the motion sure
just to be safe so Mr chairman I'd like
to make the motion to itl this Bill
thank you Miss uh representative Brown
representative kahill I'm assuming
you're still seconding oh I'll uh second
the motion the second time thank
you
okay
Mr chairman can I destroy the previous
record of votes you
may all set okay rep uh Mr clerk go
ahead okay this is Bill number HB 1258
and the motion is
itl uh Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie clerk votes
yes representative lales yes
representative Kella yes representative
n yes representative Elwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
Cahill yes representative stavis
yes representative Sykes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majori yes representative Gallagher yes
represent restive Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes uh
representative frch yes and Mr chairman
yes motion passes 19 to
zero that's much better very
good uh I assume that will go onto the
consent calendar without objection I
don't see any objections and
representative Brown you will write a
brief blurb on that for us yes I will Mr
chairman thank you very much okay with
that we'll close the hearing on HB
1258 next up will be HB
1086 relative to public notice of Zoning
Board of adjustment
hearings
we will open up the exec session on
that and I
will throw the throw this over to
representative Elward I believe you have
an amendment you would like to
introduce yes thank you very
much I'd like to introduce Amendment
0153 to house
bill
one86 this is regarding hold on thank
you uh do we have a second on the
amendment
representative Guthrie no I'm just
waiting for the clerk
here you need a copy of it you can
use
representative Guthrie
seconds now representative Elward go uh
speak to your Amendment please thank you
all right I'm very excited about this
bill regarding public
notice um I made an amendment
to get rid of the five days requirement
to post the website first of all this is
in lie of
publication and it is may be posted to
the mun municipalities internet website
so I believe that the zpas would have to
uh
perhaps amend their rules of procedure
to
to include this type of uh time period
for notice and posting to the
website so they'd have to have a meeting
I think the public could weigh in I
think that the that the
citizens should be
deciding um if they want notice this
way so I put in the
language
that the notice should be posted no
later than three business days from the
date the hearing for the appeal is
fixed so
RSA 676 col 7 public hearing
notice uh Roman 2 says the public
hearing shall be held within 45 days of
the receipt of the notice of appeal so
the zba has 45 days to to set a hearing
date now if they adopt
this posting to the website in lie of
publication if my math is
correct if hypothetically they met on
day
45 and fix the date of a hearing and
let's say that day was a Friday and then
there was a long
weekend so they would have three
business days after the long weekend to
post notice to the website that would
give non
abutters and a Butters a whopping 39
days of
notice of an application and a hearing
five days is not enough time
to possibly retain you know counsel get
the records review the pl plan and I
have seen non abutters and abutters show
up at these hearings they're completely
bewildered they're unprepared they don't
have counsel if you think of a gravel
pit
application those are uh Often by zoning
Allowed by right if it's in an
industrial zoned
area if not they have to file for
special exception which is with the zba
they don't have to go to the planning
board first they can go directly to the
zba so the more
notice that's out there and I think um
the town website would generate Word of
Mouth
advertising and the fact that a
newspaper you only have one listing on
one day you have to subscribe we we got
a uh message from the conquered monitor
I did by email and they were complaining
that
um that the newspaper is the only way to
go and I disagree I think that um
sharing information that you see on the
town website is going to be more
impactful to getting word out to the
town's people so I'm very much in favor
of this and I I hope you'll uh vote to
pass this amendment thank you thank you
representative Elward uh representative
power thank you Mr chairman I have a
process
question is
is is it appropriate for committee
members to ask questions with regards to
the amendment for clarification
absolutely if the U presenter is willing
to accept questions sure absolutely
thank you thank you um representative so
my question is
is am I correct in understanding that
this amendment that you're offering here
today changes one aspect of um of the
original Bill and that is your Amendment
on lines 5 through six compare that to
lines
15 line 15 on the the bill text so
you're CH what you're doing is that
you're saying that you're changing it
from this notice must be posted on the
website no no less than five days before
the
date for the appeal the hearing date for
the appeal no less than five days so
that gives us like five days but you're
changing your Amendment changes that
requirement to no less than three
business days from the date that the
date of that hearing for the appeal was
determined is that correct thank
you representative Jo Kell
thank you thank you for
uh um if you could respond to this this
hypothetical um it seems like there is a
question of when the
hearing for the appeal is fixed um the
requests for the uh the
application may be received by the
municipality and
and um they may not they may have a
regular regular scheduled meeting and
there's um the the person may assign the
the local official May assign that uh
hearing to the the uh next meeting but
when that occurs when they schedule it
for that next meeting um is not
necessarily transparent to the public is
it when they look at their email when
they look at their calendar when they um
receive the the actual
application um and
so for judging about whether or not the
uh the notice the the meeting was
properly noticed you would have to
determine when the actual date of the
hearing is fixed and if there wasn't a
vote by the board to fix the meeting
date then you wouldn't know particularly
when that date was fixed so you wouldn't
know where 3 days started if you see
what I'm getting at do
you if if the staff for the
um the zoning
board fixes the meeting
themselves how does the public know that
that clock has started
I believe the CBA has to meet to accept
an
application and the clock starts on the
45 days on that
date so they would have to fix the date
of a hearing within the 45
days and would post notice
within three business days of that
happening representative
stavis thank you Mr chair um
representative Elwood um I'm a grownup
person not a fourth grader and I just
did not understand at all um the mathe
mathematics behind um the change that
your amendment makes I wonder if you
could explain it to me as if I were a
fourth
grader 45 days here's 45
days the application was submitted on
the
on and the clock for 45 days starts at
that time representative El um just keep
the papers down yeah thank you you can
explain just oh
okay so in the event that was a Friday
and there was a long
weekend they would have three business
days from that date to post the
notice and that would happen at any time
during the 45 days if they met on day
30 and they fixed the date of the
hearing
for
whenever they would have three business
days after that to post the notice to
the
website representative
hollan um so I think the intent of the
bill itself was they were saying that
there's a bunch of communities that no
longer have a local newspaper and
therefore we were trying to cast we're
not we're trying to cast the widest net
to let people know that there's a really
important hearing here and we want them
to to know it's occurring and that's why
we said that they had the town website
for example in Durham we do have Fosters
Daily Democrat that that is based in
Dober but it most people in Durham are
not a lot of people in Durham are not
reading it so we're doing it locally
through a a Friday updates that the town
is putting out every week so I just I'm
confused so again the five-day not we
giving really good notice is the intent
of the of the bill I hope and so that is
5 days why would you want to cut it to
three it's like you're un it kind of
undermines the the what you're trying to
accomplish I guess is my my
thought thank you I I'll just say a
couple things I don't believe it's
cutting to three it's actually
increasing it substantially
because you're doing it has to be set
three days from the time the meeting is
set so that if I'm understanding the
amendment correctly it could actually
increase it to 15 20 30 40 days rather
than five it's it extends the way it's
written the way I read the amendment
that's what it would do uh
representative uh Power one thank you Mr
chairman I I to um I guess reiterate the
point that um representative yella was
was making is that there's confusion
with regards to this amendment and the
the way that it's worded is um
representative yella um points
out there's a concern with regards
to what defines when the meeting is
fixed is the meeting
fixed at the next time the board meets
or is it
possible that the meeting could be fixed
somehow prior to to
that I believe the answer
is okay I'm I guess I'm not sure what
the answer is I'm not on one one of
these land use boards so maybe somebody
who has experience with how the those
boards work could comment thank you
representative
Gallagher um I was just looking at the
original un amended Bill and it has the
exact same language of before the date
fixed for the hearing of the appeal
except with five days instead the only
difference I'm seeing is um in the
number there the amendment has three the
original bill has five so I think that
is pretty clear in all cases a
reduction representative
yella thank you uh Mr chair so I am on a
zba and that was actually my first first
board that I I
joined um
the in the case of my municipality we
have a standing meeting of the zba every
fourth Tuesday of the month and if we
receive uh application the the person
that receives it just assigns it to the
next meeting date um so I think the
intent of this is to say three days from
the receipt of the application and not
three dates three days from the date
that the appeal is fixed because if that
person you know was out of the office
for you know a a doctor's appointment or
something if they received that
application just because she didn't
assign it to that that uh she didn't see
and fix the date um until she got back
from the doctor's office it's still
received on the day in question and the
the three days should start from the
date received I believe uh I think that
was is the lack of clarity inside of
this um uh this uh Amendment so thank
you U representative Gilman thank you Mr
chair um I have also sat on my town zba
and the way I read this is that the zba
meets let's say the first of the month
um an appeal is made to them or is going
to be made to them um and the zba fixes
the date not the STA and the zba fixes a
date for the 30th of the month and this
is saying um no uh it needs to be posted
no later than three days for the date
fixed later in the month that
correct is that
correct representative
Elward yes I have a um note from
representative uh
Rulo he says getting back to your
amendment I think keying in on the date
of submission of the
application rather than the date of the
hearing as the anchor for setting the
time
requirements is good out of the box
thinking thank you representative
representative majori thank you Mr chair
um I'm just I was just going around the
room I think uh just looking at the the
Dems I'm not I think this is probably
still consistent with the with
Republicans every one of us has land use
experience I think that we are all I
think there's probably favorable toward
the underlying Bill and every one of us
is confused about this amendment but I'm
not hearing confusing about the
underlying bill I think the three days
cuts it short I think the three days I
think the five days is when you um when
you have the appeal not for when
scheduling but regardless this gets us
confused the bill I think we can all
agree is good
but this amendment is confusing there's
no way I can support it thank you sorry
thank you thank you for actually
speaking to the amendment representative
that was on point um I think what we
will do unless anybody wants to continue
speaking I think I would like to
representative power go ahead thank you
Mr chairman I would concur with the
representative statements I am confused
by this
and I don't want to put forward and
propagate confusion in statute and um
while this amendment is well-intentioned
it it the language is just it's not
there so I will I cannot support this
amendment as written okay so what I'm
going to suggest is that we take a vote
on the amendment um and depending on the
disposition of the underlying bill um if
that were to pass here it would go to
the other body uh once it goes to to the
other body maybe
um an amendment could be done in that
body so um we'll go ahead and ask the
clerk to call a rooll on the am uh
proposed
amendment okay this is amendment
0153 H uh Vice chairman power no
representative Guthrie no click votes no
representative
sales
I'm confused about what we're voting on
amendment I I understand it's the
amendment but the motion is
to adopt the
amendment
no uh representative yella no
representative n no representative
elwad yes representative Brown no
representative kahill uh no
Representative stavis
no representative Sykes no
representative Gilman no representative
JY no representative
Gallagher uh no representative Hicks no
representative Howland no representative
Priest No represent franch no and Mr
chairman no motion fails 18 one thank
you Mr clerk okay we're back on the uh
Bill itself HB
1086 um is there any discussion on that
representative
power do we have to have a motion
first oh yes you are correct sorry
representative power do you have a
motion no uh do we have a motion on
representative go ahead and make it not
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
motion itl on House Bill
1086 is there uh representative PRI
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chairman so um
we I received as well as probably the
committee if you checked your email um
input with regards to this this
particular Bill and while I understand
um I guess the intent of the bill there
are some concerns with the bill as
written and the concerns are
um this bill would um eliminate
the use of publication in a printed
newspaper and so there's a lot of
concerns with that with re if if the
notices were simply published on a
website there are a lot of people that
do not have internet access nor are they
digitally
literate another concern that was um
highlighted was that newspapers are
neutral whereas publication on a
government website may or may or may not
be um neutral again there's also the
accessibility with being able to um
access such a notice uh
electronically there's also um concerns
with ar archiving and verification of
the legitimacy of such a public
application with a printed newspaper
that is not so much of a con
concern and um another point that was
brought out um was that the the
inadequacy of a digital only notice um
has some serious considerations with
regards to the um permanent archival
record of such a notice that may be
needed for historical purposes as well
as for legal purposes so for those
reasons um I will be voting it on this
bill as as
written representative PRI thank you Mr
chairman I agree with all the comments
that uh the previous representative has
uh stated and I also believe in this
bill will be taking away one of the most
fundamental rights in our community and
that's freedom of the press and
I I anything we can do to strengthen
them and to strengthen their access I am
for that thank
you representative
Elwood I just want to make note that
there is nothing in um
33-3 uh- a colon 3 the disposition and
retention SC schedule there's nothing in
there about
um having to
maintain copies of legal
notices any further comments
representative gallaga um so I um I I'm
a little bit more supportive of the
basic under in concept of the bill than
the previous speakers um I think it is a
good idea to have something like this um
I do have some uh cons concerns about
the wording of this particular
implementation though it sounded like
the intent when um the bill was being
presented was to make it for places that
no longer have their um own newspaper
but looking at the existing wording it
says in lie of publication of notice in
a newspaper of General circulation um
that to me sounds like it apply even in
places where there is still a
newspaper um so I I think um I I think I
would want to see a version of um this
bill applying just to specifically to
the places where there isn't a newspaper
anymore and I'd support that version but
not this one representative yella no
yes thank you Mr chair um I support the
underlying motion or the underlying bill
and I uh don't have any issues with
um online uh
notices um we do it at the state house
um there's
no uh problem with that and I don't
think that we should m make uh uh
decisions based on kind of the the
collapsing industry of newspapers um and
trying to prop them up by giving them
Revenue uh by Statute um I don't
subscribe to a newspaper and probably
most of my generation does not so um
it's much easier for me to find this
information on a
website um than on a possible website
that is um gated um so I will be
supporting the the motion of uh a to
pass thank you represent
Frack uh thank you Mr chair I would
remind representative yella that the
majority of U New Hampshire's population
is
aging and we do not
necessarily have the computer skills to
find everything that's going on um I
think we need to look at
the overall public
good
and from my conversations with um one or
two newspaper
Publishers if this bill were taken to
its logical extent which would be all
public
notices would be required or would not
be required to be published in a
newspaper it would have significant
effects on the newspaper's ability to
provide locally oriented locally focused
news which is what keeps our local
governments honest thank you
representative K Hill thank you Mr chair
I would echo my my colleagues uh
sentiment that we have an aged
population that is still utilizing the
paper I go out for breakfast constantly
and all of the people I have breakfast
with are reading the paper I I would
also like to say that I see no
difference in propping up uh newspapers
for profits than propping up IP
providers and uh web hosting that those
Services cost money as well uh there's
really no difference um if we want to
drag in propping them up and I will
definitely be voting uh in favor of the
itl thank you for the comments
representative
Elward the conquered monitor costs
$338 a year for home and digital it
costs
$351 a year for uh all access and
home for 13 weeks at
8775 for 30 13 weeks the digital
eEdition is $
4820 a year
um if posting to a website where there
it's for many days
um and and the newspaper is only for one
day I think that it's beneficial to the
public to have it posted on the
website okay um
I think where we're at on this bill
unless there's a an extreme need to say
any more and I think we're going to have
quite a divided uh gotcha divided vote
on this one so um if if we want to
continue discussing we can do that uh
representative power thank you Mr
chairman I would like to point out that
municipalities right now can can post
these notes notices to websites without
this
bill and furthermore I would hope that
for those municipalities that do have
websites that they would do so so that
such notices are posted electronically
as well as in print
therefore
catching all demographics in the granite
state thank
you representative
Frack yes I would like to um comment on
representative kahill's suggestion that
we do not subsidize profit making
businesses and as an example I would
cite a I believe $7
million uh the member will suspend uh
try to keep
comments on the actual bill okay I'm
sorry Mr chair
thanks reprentative
majority thank you Mr chair I I guess
I'm all in on this one with a pair of
twos but uh I said before that it
sounded like we were going to support
this I'm still going to support this I I
I spoke with my town uh Planning and
Zoning administrator who thought it was
a very good idea and uh when he
circulated it uh he got some positive
support on it so I guess I'm still going
to support but I think I'm going to lose
my
hand par of twos isn't very high there
representative majority
um representative
Elward I I too spend a lot of time with
our zba chair and she supports the
bill okay thank you all right so
um as I
said if everybody could pay attention
please thank you um it looks like this
is going to be a dis um disparate
so um I I would suggest everybody votes
according to their wishes on this one if
you get my dri so with that I'm going to
ask that the clerk call a rooll and this
is on the the motion of uh itl by
representative power on HB
1086 okay thank you Mr chairman uh Vice
chairman power yes representative
Guthrie click votes yes
representative Salis
no representative yella
no representative n
yes representative Ood
no representative Brown yes
representative kahill
yes Representative stavis
no representative Sykes
yes representative
yes Representative majori
no representative
Gallagher so um this being the itl
motion I vote
Yes representative Hicks
no representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
franch yes and Mr chairman
yes a motion passes 13 to6
okay so that was an itail motion of uh
itl
representative Vice chair um Power I
assume you will write a
blurb in support of your
motion and hold on um is there anybody
who well can we first of all can we put
this any objections to putting it on the
consent
calendar okay okay we have objections to
put it on it nope you have not
been I mean I think hold on uh so we
need representative stavis who will be
writing the blurb for
the OTP well against
citl do we have anybody who voted
against C itl representative majority
you will write the blur anybody else
raing their was anybody else raising
their hand I'm fine with that okay
you're it
okay
so representative kahill what is this in
regards to turn on your mic the clerk
read the vote is 15 to
six oh 13
13 okay with
that executive session on 1086 is now uh
closed
what a nightmare that
was
okay next up will be HB
1342 relative to the licensing of
electronic literary materials by
libraries
and we'll open up EXA session on that I
believe representative yella has a
motion on that yes thank you Mr chair I
move
itl thank you do we have a second on
that representative Hicks seconds
representative Brown could you turn off
your mic please thank
you okay
um I'll speak to that if you don't mind
um the the prime sponsor of that and I
had several discussions um about the the
underlying Bill itself and the potential
for it even seeing the light of day he
agreed that it was not ready at all and
he would support um the committee it
telling so that's what we're going to do
on that one so we unless there's any
discussion on this seeing none we'll
just call the rooll on
this once the clerk is ready take your
time hey
uh
y okay the motion is on HB 1342 itl uh
Vice chairman in power yes
representative Guthrie clerk votes yes
representative lales yes yes
representative yella yes representative
n yes representative award yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill yes representative stavis
yes representative Sykes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majori yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
howand yes representative priest yes
representative Frank
yes and Mr chairman yes motion passes 19
to Z thank you Mr Clark uh without
objection go on the consent
calendar and uh I'll I'll actually write
the blurb on that one
representative or was that one you
already wrote I I already wrote it but
you can put your name on it or rewrite
it sorry about that I couldn't remember
if that was one no representative yo
Kella will write the blur on that sorry
about
that that closes the exact session on
1341 next up will be
HB 1105 FN local
relative to an application of a local
tax cap we will open open the exec
session on that bill and I understand
representative power you have a
motion um Mr chairman I I have an
amendment to
offer go ahead thank you um I'd like to
offer Amendment
d212 to House Bill
1105 FN
local second thank you representative
McDonald seconds that Amendment proposed
amendment and represent power would you
like to speak to that yes thank you Mr
chairman So based on the um the
input during the bill
hearing it was um noted that the word
Appropriations in my amended language
was in
precise and I worked with New Hampshire
Municipal Association I um proposed
three variations to clarify that word
Appropriations and we settled on the
terms on the words warrant articles with
a tax impact I appreciate that input and
that um more clearly and specifically
um
achieves what I wanted to um with this
Bill thank
you are there any comments on represent
Holland uh thank you Mr sherett so I I
think uh the underlying Bill what we
were concerned with was when you said
Appropriations was it gross
appropriation or was it actually the net
appropriation which I guess in her
flowchart was really great and so uh I
think the and I think this is probably
the most Wordsmith statement that we've
ever done as a non- tax cap Community
when we're talking about our budget goal
this is always our focus and I think the
amendment really helps to fix it and
clarify it and I think moving into any
budget uh cycle where you begin to talk
about what either your tax cap or your
budget goal and having Clarity in that
is really important as you move through
the difficult decisions so I I think the
amendment is a good one thank you
further
comments seeing none we will ask the
clerk to call a rooll on the
amendment okay Bill 1105 Amendment 0212
H uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie clerk votes yes
representative lalis yes representative
yella yes representative n yes
representative award yes yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill yes uh representative stavis yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Gilman yes representative majori yes
representative Gallagher yes and
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative franch yes and Mr
chairman yes uh motion passes 19 to zero
thank you Mr clerk do I have a another
motion representative power thank you Mr
chairman I move ought to pass as amended
on House Bill
1105 thank you and representative
McDonald seconds that is there further
discussion on that motion and the
bill did you want to speak to it or yes
thank you Mr chairman so um the purpose
of the bill is to Simply clarify the
statute pertaining to a local tax cap
and um it doesn't expand it doesn't
change the local tax cap it just simply
makes it very clear um what is to be
included in the calculation for the tax
cap and in doing so it upholds the
legislative intent of this section of
Statute thank you representative
Gallagher
um
I um I'll be voting against this just
because I oppose tax caps on principle
and don't want to be seen as doing
anything that might be taking part in
strengthening one thank you further
comments seeing none when the clerk is
ready could we call the rule on 11:05
otpa okay uh Vice chairman of power yes
representative Guthrie yes clerk votes
yes representative Salis yes
representative yella yes representative
n yes representative Alwood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill yes representative stavis
yes representative Sykes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
majori yes representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative
yes representative frch yes and Mr
chairman yes motion passes 18
to1 without objection that will go on
the consent calendar seeing no
objections and I assume representative
power will write the
blur okay with that that closes the
heing on HB
[Music]
next up we will be discussing
HB
1461 we will open up an exec session on
that okay um I believe representative
priest would like to propose an
amendment uh I would like to propose
that this bill go into interim
study oh okay we were anticipating
something else okay um is there a second
on the inter room study representative
stavis sorry go represent stavis
uh seconds the motion of interim
study is there any discussion
on represent
PRI
I think this bill is very important and
we've just received the amendment from
the sponsor and I think I want to make
sure that we're all clear and that um
it's something that we can live with and
that's why I'm going with interim study
thank you thank you
representative um I I would strongly
second
that that idea that getting such a
lengthy Amendment right before the
hearing is not
uh the best way to do business so we
appreciate the interim study bill uh is
there any further discussion on
that representative Guthrie yes I just
like to comment that the uh and just
taking a quick look at the amendment
that does still say representative GTH
three we're not speaking to the
amendment but we're on the we're on an
motion of interim study so if you want
to speak to the main bill you can do
that but we're not the main the main
bills says all all meetings not just
that it doesn't specify particular
meetings as long as the article of the
uh Amendment said all I'd be opposed to
uh I would vote against this so that I
could
itl thank thank you Mr chairman thank
you further comments
questions seeing none we'll ask the
clerk to call
um the motion of interim study on HB
1461 okay uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie no clerk votes
yes representative
lales yes representative
yella yes representative n yes
representative Elward yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
representative stavis yes
uh representative Sykes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
major yes representative gallager yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative FR yes Mr chairman yes
motion passes 18 to zero uh 18 to one
I'm sorry thank you Mr clerk uh without
objection on to the consent calendar
again representative priest will write
the blur I assume thank you very much
okay with that that closes the exact
session on
1461 while the clerk gets ready for
1544 uh 1708 is next was next on the
agenda however uh yesterday afternoon I
received a call from the house Judiciary
Committee asking if we might not exec
this so they could attach potentially
the that bill over to some other
legislation that they're dealing with
that is very very similar so I acceded
to that request so we're not going to
act on it today uh we'll hold it in OB
bance in case something goes astray over
there but um for now we are just going
to let that one sit in committee without
action
all right representative saus Mr chair
this is a question for you it's a
procedural question um since you have
spoken you just you have spoken with the
other committee on this bill and it is
still our bill um what input advice will
we be seeking from the members of this
committee as that bill goes forward or
is there some other process that will
take place that we will have an
opportunity to comment on whereby this
committee gives over this bill vacates
this bill corre the other committee
corre again we will hold this in
abayance so
if the contents of the original bill is
not
um done over in judiciary we will still
have authority over the bill whether or
not we decide to go forward with it or
not
um I guess that they will have to hold a
hearing on non
gerain um on a non- gerain bill in
judiciary so I would say if there's
comments from anybody on the committee
who wants to speak to that when they not
notice that uh
nonchain bill that maybe show up in
judiciary to make the comments heard um
again I I received prior
PR to us holding the hearing we C we
can't at this point um vacate the bill
over there we can't do that because
we've already held the hearing held a
hearing on this so the only way of this
being allowed over there is through a
non- gerain amendment in
judiciary um I heard several individuals
on this committee prior mentioned that
this bill should have been in judiciary
to begin with which
after unfortunately after our our
hearing I kind of agree with so for now
it'll be over in judiciary or they they
asked us not to exec I'll leave it at
that representative
PRI uh Mr chairman wouldn't the more
appropriate would be to uh take this to
interim
study what we will do is do nothing at
this point because we
want if they fail to do
anything over there
um I know where you're going
I'm I know where you're going with that
however um I was asked by the chair of
Judiciary if I would not exec this today
and and I'm going
to at some point again if things don't
go as we would like to see I I think
that's we'll act on it within committee
lat
thank you represent stav thank you Mr
chair and try to be brief with this a
previous bill that we had that the
sponsor requested that we not go forward
with it we voted to itl that
bill what is the difference here simply
because the chair of judicial Affairs
requested it rather than the sponsor and
how how do we as a committee that now
now owns this bill get to track the
progress of the bill without attending
every judicial Affairs hearing I'm just
concerned that not so much that that
committee won't do anything but what
they might actually do after we've had
the hearing and raised questions
and had our own thoughts about it and I
am sympathetic to exactly what you're
saying and what representative priest
said before thank you uh
do you have a question representative
McDonald no oh Mike's on okay
representative k um just would it be
appropriate first to make a motion to
retain the bill can we do that to
ourselves retains are not allowed in the
second year would be interim study as
representative priest mentioned but I
I'm not going to bring the the bill up
for exec session
today representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman so
procedurally as the chairman you can you
can can do this or do we have to vote on
this not I can do that we're just I'm
not bringing the bill forward for exec
session thank
you okay and with all of that uh we will
move on to HB
1544 relative to indemnification for
municipalities adopting policies to
address uh
homelessness and I believe
representative stavis has a
motion oh I'm sorry
uh representative Gallagher do you have
an amendment propos um yes I do but all
right so I had my own Amendment drafted
ahead of time which I distributed at the
Committee hearing last night via email
um I received um or I think we all
received um an amendment from um
representative grassy
um about how he wishes uh for us to
amend the bill um I think um it would be
good to consider both of them but I'm
not really sure how to proceed like um
what the order should be here whether we
should do mine first or his first or um
so yeah to avoid confusion and just so
we can have longer to um consider
amendments I'm going to the same thing
that representative priest did with the
previous Bill and instead move that uh
we go to interim study on the
bill very good representative Gallagher
is there a second on the interim study
motion representative howand seconds
that
is there any uh discussion
on HP
1544 represent power so just to clarify
I'm speaking on the motion to interim
study correct that is correct okay so
the reason uh I agreed with uh
representative Gallagher on the interim
study I had some significant concerns
with the actual bill um last year we had
a bill come forward uh which really
talked about I'm not going to call it
temporary housing I going to call it
transitional housing and it really came
up that larger uh
municipalities that had particularly if
they had Hotel uh space were really
bearing the brunt of transitional
housing and they were asking for other
communities that were that had residents
that they were shipping to them that
they were paying their fair share of it
and so so I think that's the underlying
issue that we have with transitional
housing I think the bill itself in terms
of talking about the barrier of uh
legally to creating that temporary
housing is an interesting one but I
think there's a lot more work that needs
to be done on what that transitional
housing looks like and so I think it
would help if we did an interim study
that we could clarify that and would
make the bill better as it came back to
us thank you representative uh further
comments
seeing none we will ask the
clerk to call a rooll on interim study
for hb15 44 okay Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie clerk votes yes
uh representative L sales yes
representative yella yes representative
n yes representative Elward yes
representative Brown yes Representative
kahill
no representative stavis yes
uh representative Sykes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
mjy yes representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative frch yes and Mr
chairman
yes motion passes 18 to
one thank you uh without objection this
will go once again on to the consent
calendar uh
representative Gallagher will you be
writing the blur for that or would you
um sure okay
you okay with that that closes the
representative statement oh okay uh that
closes the exec session on HB
while I'm thinking about it and as the
clerk gets ready for the next bill uh
blurbs try to get those to me as soon as
you can anybody who's pre-drafted them
it would I could take th I could take
those immediately and we could get them
into the uh calendar so it could go on
February
1st uh proposed our first house session
day but um please do get them to me as
soon as you can thank
you represent
Holland I'm
kidding uh okay HB uh 1641 FN local will
be next and that is relating to
requiring large parking lots to have a
solar power canopy we will open up the
exess session on that I believe
representative stavis you have a motion
Mr chair I would like to move itl on
HB excuse me HP4
1641 thank you do we have a do we have a
second on that all kinds of seconds
representative
Hicks and would you like to speak to
that representative stavis thank you Mr
chair if I can get rid of this frog in
my throat I'd love to speak to
it I think that the um the intent of
this bill is a good one um there is much
to be gained from
utilizing what you could call empty
spaces for solar arrays but I thought
that wasn't well thought out enough in
terms of it
technicalities there was no mention of
you know little things like net metering
and how is that monitored and who uses
the electricity generated from these
solar arrays and how do planning and
zoning boards account for this when they
are considering projects for say
housing uh so um given all of the work
that needs to go into this
well-intentioned bill I'm nonetheless
moving to itl thank you representative
further comments uh representative
priest Mr chairman thank you for um
acknowledging me um I will also be
voting to itl this even though I am a
very strong supporter of solar energy I
just think um this has many questions
that are not answered and um I think
this really would be a burden on local
governments as well as private business
without having some funding identified
uh for this implementation thank you
thank you further comments represent
Gallagher um I agree that the uh bill
could use some work um but I just think
that um we could do like we have with
the previous bills and that um interim
study might be a better Avenue for
working out some of these issues
identified with it so um I'll
respectfully be voting against the itl
motion thank you representative further
comments representative Holland so I'm
going to support the itl motion uh just
because uh I think there's a lot of
problems with this in terms of uh the
state imposing the solar um in Durham we
actually did build a solar canopy we did
it on our school uh because the site was
so small we had actually filled the
entire uh roof of the building with
solar and we just didn't and we still
needed more capacity to run our heat
pumps and the only place we could do it
was by doing a solar canopy and it's the
most expensive way to do solar um my
concern with this is especially in uh
the bill we w we would very rapidly all
of our parking spaces would become
Static because we'd be sticking solar
over them so it would really inhibit the
ability of the municipality to begin to
think about how they're going to
restructure or work on their uh their
downtown areas or a lot of their areas
so I think last session uh
representative stavis represent uh
presented a bill that really spoke to
putting it in the master plan and the
planning process and I think that's the
location that this really uh should go
and I don't think putting this bill in
interim study will get us there so again
I support the itl thank you
representative uh
power thank you Mr chairman I support
the motion of itl because owners of
large parking facilities can already do
what this bill sets forward to do
without this
Bill thank you further comments seeing
none I'll ask the clerk to call a rooll
on the itail motion for
1641 okay thank you Mr chairman uh Vice
chairman power yes representative
Guthrie yes CL votes yes representative
lalis yes representative yella yes
representative n yes representative
Elwood yes representative Brown yes
representative Cahill yes representative
stavis yes representative Sykes yes
representative Gilman yes representative
Maury yes representative Gallagher no
representative Hicks yes representative
Howland yes representative priest yes
representative frch yes and Mr chairman
yes motion passes 18 to one thank you Mr
clerk uh again this will go on to the
consent calendar unless there's any
objection I see
none uh
rep represent sis you will be writing
the blurb on that one thank you okay
with that that closes the exact session
on 1641
FN okay we're down to our last one exact
bill for the morning that will be HB
1396 relative to prohibiting Municipal
inspections of owner occupied
units of uh multi-unit housing we'll
open up the ex session on that and I
believe representative yella has a
motion thank you Mr chair I move ought
to pass is that second
I second that Mr chairman representative
Brown seconds that motion uh
representative yull would you like to
speak to your motion sure thank you um I
think that that um the property right
issue is an important one and protecting
of um your property rights uh is
something that we should uh encourage in
this committee and I think that um just
because you choose to rent out other
units you should not have reduced uh
control over your own unit um and I
believe that there is
some the the claims for uh you know the
sky is falling because of of safety I
think that uh the people that uh are
in condos which share walls with people
that they don't know or have any
relationship with um share that
same uh quote risk if you if you uh
believe that there is such a risk um and
those people in the condos don't lose
their their property rights and so I
don't believe these people in the
renting structure should lose those
property rights even though um the exact
same
building uh with the exact same
structure and all of that um could be in
either of those cases a a rental unit or
uh a condo and so uh since the structure
is literally the same it's just the
ownership that is different um I don't
see one being given preferential treat
treatment as uh in accordance to
property rights as being
um um commensurate with our our uh right
to privacy in our constitution so thank
you very much thank you representative
Joe Kella are there any further
comments representative
priest yes I would
um oppose what the previous speaker has
stated I think the health and
safety of the residents in these units
are more important than the property
rights of the owner occupied unit thank
you thank you further comments
representative
Brown U although I tend to agree with
representative priest about the property
owner's rights that are renting I also
look at this from the point of view of
if you own a townhouse that has a common
wall those those people are separate
owners of the property and they don't do
don't get inspected for the same type of
reasons thank you represent
svis thank you Mr chair just um as a
condominium owner myself and knowing
many condominium owners they are in fact
liable for risks to the common area if
they share a roof if somebody else's
roof goes bad everybody pays for that
roof uh and it's a risk to everyone so
that is actually in fact not true that
um condominium owners are exempt from
this kind of
inspection further comments uh
representative uh
K yeah I totally agree with my colleague
uh representative priest you know um
having worked in the uh constru industry
my whole life I understand inspecting a
firewalls and things like that and what
can go wrong on the other side of a wall
um people can drill holes in walls we we
heard lots of testimony when this bill
came before us last year and and now um
of the safety concerns and security
concerns and I I will be voting against
the
OTP representative Helen so again we did
hear this last year and I I think when
the bill arose the concern really was
that a municipality would put forward a
yearly inspection and they' come forward
and then and the homeowner or the the
owner occupied was like wait a second
why am I being uh inspected every year I
think the concern that was raised in the
public hearing really would be if the
owner occupied pulled a permit to do
something on their unit that this bill
would prohibit the code enforcement to
come and look at it so to put that in
perspective I I'm a single family
homeowner if I pull a
permit they're going to come inspect my
unit it's like that's part of the
process and so I think this so in terms
of property rights I I I mean I by me
pulling a permit I'm asking you know
that part of the process is they're
going to inspect it to make sure it
meets code and so I think this inhibits
the code enforcement I mean while I do
understand the difficulty of the yearly
thing and maybe that could be addressed
in the future the next time this bill
comes forward the actual code
enforcement we don't want to weaken so I
I think that we want to itl this
bill for the
comments
uh we will take
a 10
minute caucus for the
Republicans so we do that with Amendment
with a motion on the floor I'm sorry Mr
chair I don't know that's a good
question I don't know the answer a
motion on the floor I think we have to
act I don't know the answer to that hold
on
can you withdraw the motion is
that
okay procedurally this is how it goes
according to the clerk um if we were in
the middle of a vote no we cannot in
fact take a recess or quick break if we
are still under discussion of the motion
yes we can so with that we will take a
10-minute break until
11:45 and we would
ask the Democrats to kindly take a quick
walk bathroom
break also we'll ask that the
individuals in the back of the room um
vacate for a few minutes until 11:45
thank
you and uh representative Brown could
you get the caucus sign and put it up on
the
okay sorry about
that is everybody back I believe so okay
so we were having a discussion on HB
1396 is there any further
discussion before I call a vote because
then we can't have a
recess seeing none we'll ask you have a
motion we have a motion and that motion
is OTP by representative yella Mr clerk
could you call the
vote okay uh Vice shman power
yes representative
Guffy cler votes yes representative
lalis
yes representative yella yes
representative n yes representative
awood yes representative Brown yes
Representative kahill
no Representative stavis
no representative Sykes
no representative Gilman no represent
maity no representative
Gallagher
um sorry M remind me of the motion again
it's um OTP so
no okay uh representative Hicks
no Representative hman
no representative Priest No
representative F no Mr chairman
yes okay motion fails 8 to 11
okay that motion fails do we have
another motion representative PR yes I
would like to itl this
motion the bill oh yeah representative
priest uh motions itl is there a second
representative
stavis all right I'm assuming we don't
need any further discussion on the itl
anybody want to talk about
it
okay we'll ask the clerk to call the
role representative priest could you
turn your mic
up okay uh Vice chairman in power
no representative Guthrie
yeah clect votes no Representative silus
no representative Kella
no uh representative another no
representative Arwood no representative
Brown no representative kahill oh
yes representative stavis yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Gilman yes representative majori yes
representative Gallagher yes
representative Hicks yes representative
howand yes representative priest yes
representative French yes and Mr
chairman uh
no motion passes 11
to8 okay I assume this will not go on
the consent calendar so representative
priest the motion maker I'll you'll do
the blurb on that on the itel motion
representative yo Kella probably did the
same thing you will do the blur for do
you want me to change the one that I
already gave you might have to reward it
a little bit but other than that yes so
you'll do that that's fine
okay
so uh with that I think we are closed on
the exact for
1396 all right so here is
the deal going
forward so we're doing good on time time
we are scheduled to be back at
1 uh I'll ask that you be back at about
110 and here's the reason uh the prime
sponsor of
1317 has agreed to merge his bill in
with a previous Bill we've heard so uh
he's asked that we itl that so that'll
be a quick one so at 110 we'll have
everybody back however before you leave
couple couple things that uh would like
to to go over uh based
on most of it is regarding when we're
we're sitting here as a committee Andor
especially during uh when we have
individuals testifying up there um
remember that when somebody
testifies the questions that we can ask
them are based on their testimony okay
so in other words we we don't go off
into the Weeds on other items that are
in directly related to their testimony
if you want further Clarity on their
testimony or something like that but we
got to keep it on topic um I've been a
little LAX in in keeping people in line
on that and last week we went very long
on some of the bills where we really
didn't need to
um let's see the other thing that was
brought up to me by a few individuals
was it's up to this committee when you
we come to hit uh to our hearings
especially on like on the bills we're
going to hear this afternoon come
prepared know what's in the bill and
when questions are asked of the
individuals given the
testimony listen to the
answers um so questions aren't repeated
so come prepared listen to the testimony
listen to the questions so we don't have
to repeat um the other thing remember
we're always on a video here uh we're
was on video and we're also
uh now that I have everybody's attention
um we're always on video and we're we're
always on the mic also so be uh make
sure what you're doing what you're
saying is what you mean to be doing and
saying the last point I'll make um
I've said this before and here and I
think you guys pretty much know it when
I call on individuals to ask questions
or whatever I I go from Republican
Democrat Republican Democrat if you've
already spoken once I'm going to bypass
you and go to somebody who hasn't spoken
um you don't have once I you put your
hand up and I acknowledge you and I see
you you can put your hand down I know
you're there I'm going to get back to
you and if I forget then frantically
wave at me so other than that um if you
have any questions represent
s yeah I would like to respectfully ask
if this is something the chair thinks is
appropriate that members of the
committee when listening to people
presenting bills or testimony
hold this kind of gesture until the
person is done with their testimony I I
I just feel that it's rude and it's a
sign that we're not really listening if
we've got our hands in the air and the
person is still speaking which goes to
exactly what I just talked about about
the hands absolutely correct and that's
the other thing I said we're always on
video we're always being watched
um hands don't need to be up the whole
time I most of the time unless it's
representative Gilman who I have a hard
time seeing down there I I see you so
you don't have to uh sorry
representative but I have a hard time
with you um so yes I I would totally
agree with you 100% so all right with
that represent K my apologize if my hand
being up the whole time I'm used to just
grade school where where you hold your
hand up until you're called on not an
issue just been a few years this isn't
wasn't focused at you this is in general
we we've all been guilty of some of
these things including myself so
representative may I announce that there
will be um Refreshments for lunch if
they're interested sure uh when you say
that you're talking about your cupcakes
and whatever okay yeah sure um just
don't bring them out in here kind of put
it is there a table around the corner
here yeah yeah yeah oh there
isn't away all right well I guess we'll
make an exception have it down your end
represent
Brown
1:0 no later because we will start
promptly at
110 you
may that was our scheduled time anyway
so that's fine let me let me consult my
my magic wand here okay with that we
will see everybody back at
1:10
for
okay everybody we're going to start in
two minutes just take your seats
please to
you no I I think that was a
generic
okay we're going to get going here folks
um first of all we're going to start
with uh HB 1317 I misspoke prior I used
the wrong word we are not exing this
bill we are going to introduce
it um and then we are just going to hold
it in committee uh to be exact at a
later date um as I explained
the uh the prime sponsor and uh our
clerk are working to merge similar bills
into one so this will be an itl not
today we never exec a bill the same day
unless it's already in the calendar so
we won't be doing that and I I did you I
think I did use that word because
several people mentioned it afterwards I
didn't mean to so uh hb1
1317 uh representative power since
you're sitting there we're just going to
have you introduce it and then we can
move
on
yeah so we are open up the hearing on
1317 FN local relative to Municipal
filings made by charitable organization
exempt from taxation representative
power thank you Mr chairman
um I appreciate um the opportunity here
to introduce to you house bill
1317 relative to Municipal filings made
by charitable organizations exempt from
taxation this bill allows for late fees
for charitable tax exe tax exemption
filings with municipalities and
specifies examples of good cause for tax
abatements thank you seeing no comments
or questions for representative power
we'll close the hearing on HB
13117 uh we have two minutes and we'll
start on your
bill
okay the clock over there I see says 120
so we
will we will open up the hearing on hb1
1281 relative to zoning restrictions on
residential rental part uh property
representative power thank you Mr
chairman and honorable committee members
as the prime sponsor I appreciate the
opportunity to introduce to you today
House Bill
1281 for the record I am representative
Diane power I represent the towns of
Brookline Mason in Greenville in
Hillsboro County District
36 to begin this bill was filed upon the
request of a large group of concerned
citizens this is a straightforward
Common Sense Bill the purpose of this
bill is to prohibit municipalities from
enacting and enforcing ordinances that
restrict the number of unrelated
occupants living in a residential rental
property the problem that this bill
seeks to address is this currently some
municipalities have enacted ordinances
that arbitrarily and unreasonably limit
the number of unrelated occupants
allowed to rent a residential dwelling
unit for example in some municipalities
a landlord owning a five-bedroom house
is prohibited by local ordinances from
renting the property to no more than
three unrelated renters when clearly the
house can reasonably accommodate at
least five unrelated renters that's one
occupant per bedroom also consider that
the landlord as well as the prospective
renters may both be comfortable with two
renters per bedroom or 10 individuals
living in this five-bedroom
house in this example local ordinances
have the effect of artificially
eliminating housing opportunities for
seven people seeking housing
unmistakably local Z zoning ordinances
that restrict the number of unrelated
occupants living in a residential rental
property are highly problematic in many
ways first and foremost most overly
restrictive ordinances constitute
infringement by government upon the
property rights of individuals to freely
utilize their property as they see fit
in a responsible manner that does not
pose any Genuine Health and or safety
concerns furthermore if health and
safety is the alleged basis for such
ordinances then it would logically
follow that such restrictions on
residential property should apply to all
residences whether privately owned or
rented in practice this is unmistakably
not the case to be clear households of
related persons are not subject to these
particular restrictive
ordinances second overreaching
ordinances imposed by m municipalities
that go beyond health and safety is one
example of land use ordinances that
negatively impacts both affordability
and supply of housing in the granite
state by arbitrarily re restricting the
use of
preavis
housing currently New Hampshire has an
inadequate supply of affordable housing
not to mention a severe shortage of
rental housing to be clear restrictive
ordinances drive up rental costs and
they reduce the number of housing units
further compounding the Hampshire's
housing
crisis in 2023 for a two-bedroom rental
Statewide there was a 6 vacancy with a
median gross monthly rent of
$1,764 third these types of restrictive
ordinances are unfair to say the very
least sadly I heard from one property
landlord who shared with me that he had
a house available
for rent that four unrelated black men
wanted to rent together this property
could have more than easily accommodated
all four men providing them with housing
when the property owner explained to the
men that he couldn't rent to them
because the town restricted all rentals
to no more than three unrelated people
the men legitimately thought that the LA
landlord was being discriminatory and
racist towards them because the men
explained that they knew of eight
unrelated Chinese restaurant workers
living together in a rental house in the
very same town fourth consider the many
reasons for which unrelated individuals
might seek to share housing college
students share housing in order to be
able to afford room board and
tuition working Professionals of all
ages may share housing to reduce
expenses and others might find
themselves in difficult situations such
as persons widowed divorced or retired
people living on fixed or low incomes
people who have downsized or who are
experiencing loss of employment the
elderly and the disabled are about a few
examples to come to to that come to my
mind these groups of people may choose
and even need to share housing costs and
expenses in order to avoid
homelessness Now understand that New
Hampshire is a Dylan's rural State
accordingly a local government's
authority to regulate housing occupancy
is derived from the power granted by the
state legislature to protect health
safety and general
welfare thus when this local Authority
is used in a manner that is blatantly
overreaching and extends Beyond these
expressed objectives then it is
incumbent M upon the state legislature
to intervene on behalf of its citizens
for this reason this bill provides the
appropriate guard rails to local use
planning and Regulatory powers granted
by the state legislature to
municipalities next this brings us to
the solution to the obvious problem this
bill before you adds a new paragraph
under RSA 674 colon 16 zoning Authority
rental occupancy
lines 3-9 prohibits legislative bodies
of specified political subdivisions of
the state from adopting and or enforcing
any local law that restricts the number
of occupants of a residential rental
property to less than two unrelated
renters per bedroom and lines 9 through
14 prohibits legislative bodies of a
specified political subdivision of the
state from adopting Andor enforcing ing
any local law that requires the
existence of familial relationships
among the occupants of a residential
rental property in conclusion by
prohibiting municipalities from enacting
and enforcing local laws that restrict
the number of unrelated occupants living
in a
residential rental property this bill
will uphold the inherent rights of
property owners guard against unfair
practices and unwarranted discrimination
in rental housing increase the supply of
pre-existing housing which in turn will
hopefully help to lower rental costs for
granite Staters Mr chairman that
concludes my Bill intro introduction I'm
happy to answer any questions relative
to the bill language itself however in
the interest of time I'd recommend that
all other questions be deferred to
expert Witnesses and others here to
testify on this Bill thank you thank you
thank you representa power
representative y
Kella thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking the question it seemed from
your testimony that
you were advocating for
restricting uh discrimination by
municipalities based on familial status
but it seemed that the language that you
described only said that they couldn't
restrict it to X number of non-related
employees or uh tenants and not uh an
outright prohibition on discrimination
based on familiar status why did you um
not go all the way to just say no
discrimination at all thank you for the
question representative
um unfortunately I don't really
understand your question and in my my
mind it it's it's very clear to me that
and as I described with regards to the
bill language it
itself I addressed the issue of some
municipalities having ordinances on the
books that restrict the number of
unrelated
renters and I put in a a reasonable um
alternative to a to a blank check to
that and additionally I I took another
step to potentially close a loophole in
response to this and said that no
municipality May enact and enforce an
ordinance that requires familial
relationships in order to
rent I hope that that answers your
question that I didn't
understand represent
PRI thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question and thank you for being here
how many communities in New Hampshire
would you guess is are putting
restrictions on Residential Properties
thank you representative that's a very
interesting question
so back in the fall I went to the
research Department here in conquer and
I sat down with them in person and
requested that um research be done
to answer that question for some unknown
reason I never got any response for them
so therefore I needed to conduct the
research myself so in doing so
um I didn't look at every single
municipality in New Hampshire due to
time and when I did with from the
research that I did um do I identified
seven and I'm happy to um pass that
information along to you after the
hearing followup representative PRI yes
and did you take an account the parking
requirements for these Residential
Properties and if you open it up to two
people per bedroom unrelated how many
what what would be the impact of these
Residential Properties thank you for the
question representative my focus in
filing this bill was specifically on the
the Restriction in ordinances with
regards to the number of of individuals
that were unrelated that could could
rent that was my
focus I did not I understand that
there's there's a parking Factor but
like I said I focused on the use of the
property and the property rights of the
proper property
owner representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you represent of power
I have a couple questions and as you
indicated before you might have some
experts that are going to be able to
testify to this so maybe you can let me
know if they're going to do this concern
about septic systems fire ESS and what
the typical occupancy might be on a
three-bedroom home um so you could look
at what the total number of people might
be occupying a space would be from a
kind of zoning safety Public Safety type
of
issue thank you representative for the
question so um we it's my understanding
that when you know when you have a house
it's it's completely
reasonable that two
people should reasonably be able to to
occup occupy um you know a bedroom space
and while I'm not a home builder it is
also my understanding that when homes
are built with with bedrooms that that
is most likely the um I guess the
calculus or a requirement that goes into
when a builder builds a home as to how a
septic system is going to be sized
therefore my bill will have no adverse
impacts with regards to um septic
furthermore if these properties are in
municipalities that have
public sewer that would not be a con you
know that would not be a a consider a
factor if you
will thank you representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um is it your
understanding that
the relational status of individuals
living in rental housing has any impact
whatsoever on septic or sewer
capacity thank you for the question
representative
um whether people are unrelated or or
related they're they're individuals and
I don't see how that's going to change
um septic
capacity of
Guthrie thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh I really have two
related one has already been asked that
about the septic system I suggest to you
would this would have a big impact uh
but I'm concerned about the social
impact if this could re could could not
this bill uh result in having say a a
condominium with I don't know eight or
10 units and you got 50 people living in
there and then and you know and there's
no control over over that over a period
of time when that have a social
impact thank you for the question
representative so to
reiterate this
bill
specifies
that there may not be that it guarantees
and allows up to two people per bedroom
if the landlord you know has a
five-bedroom house and they just want to
rent it to one person they they can
still rent it to one
person the bill prohibits unreasonable
restrictions placed on property
owners through ordinances so again to
reiterate two persons per bedroom is
completely reasonable that that's not
that's not stuffing 50 people into a
house and so you know to answer your
second question I I don't see that there
would be some social you know
impact if this bill were to be signed in
into law no I thank you for your
answers representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question um
I'm looking at this just the the
grammatically and I uh tell me that I'm
wrong when I read it uh let's see uh
lines four to
five uh or six you list off a city Town
Village District or county in which
there are located unincorporated towns
or or unorganized
places um when I'm looking at this to me
it means all of those things that have
unincorporated places or do you mean
just a county that has unincorporated
places it's the comma business thank you
for the yeah thank you for the question
representative um I appreciate that so
um OSS drafted this bill and it was
drafted by a uh an attorney who special
specializes in Municipal law so um it's
there it's their wording so um to answer
your question the way that I read it is
is that the words on line six refer back
to County it's a modifying the word
County yeah okay thank
you further
questions I have one representative
power that came
up when you started talking about uh
five bedroom homes it started I started
having visions of some of these old
Victorian houses with five six seven
eight
bedrooms
and I don't know the answer to this
would as you start filling those
bedrooms with two people per bedroom do
we start getting into a scenario of a
boarding house situation and are
there laws and regulations against that
thank you for the question chairman so
um when I was doing the research with
regards to local ordinances
as I was looking through the zoning or
ordinances to answer your question that
would have to do with the definition of
a boarding
house
and given any particular Town how how do
they Define a boarding house so I can't
answer that that question it it would
have to be on a case-by casee basis
thank you thank you further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony
uh going to call we've got several pin
cards what I'm going to ask we have a
lot of them um we're going to try to
keep keep your time
to three or four minutes maximum so we
don't have to actually start timing you
all um for those who come later in the
pink card call up uh please if you if
it's the points have already been made
Please Do Not Duplicate we have a bunch
of cards and we would like to get
through and remain on time first one we
have coming up uh Jeffrey
Berlin hello Representatives thank you
for your time today um I'd actually like
to start off with answering some of the
questions maybe a little bit more um
that were just previously asked so um
with respect to parking um there's
already existing was it you that asked
about parking there's already existing
parking service parking surface rules
setback regulations that will already
limit that I'm actually going to speak
to the extent at which they have uh the
town that I live in Durham has gone to
actually go above and beyond um handling
the cars so there's other ways that they
can manage that um the septic most of
the um someone over here asked about SE
most of the properties that are subject
to this are on Town Water and Sewer so
that shouldn't be an issue as
well um I'm going to just what I had
prepared now some of it is
um in conjunction to what Diane has
already mentioned um but it's first
person testimony for myself so um going
to give it now so representatives of the
house Municipal and County government
committee my name is Jeff Berlin I thank
you for your time today and I'm sorry
for any stuttering or misspoken words I
am a stakeholder in an issue that for me
started as a property rights issue but
is since morphed into emotional topics
involving Financial hardships of of both
landlords and tenants abuse of power
from Municipal entities stalking Believe
It or Not by Municipal representatives
lawfare of both tenants and Property
Owners trespassing on private property
and culminating in the realization that
the biggest issue surrounding this bill
is actually one of a massive fair
housing
violation not a violation of law because
a person who is required Ed to have a
familial relationship with another
person in order to live together isn't a
protected class under Fair Housing but a
violation of decency and fairness which
house bill 1281 would
correct plainly stated Bill 1281 seeks
to Outlaw a city or town from regulating
the number of occupants allowed in a
dwelling unit based on familial
relationship I grew up in Durham about a
mile from UNH I went to high school in
Durham
graduated in 2006 and proceeded to
attend UNH first semester after that
went to endicot college where I majored
in Real Estate Management Finance came
back to Durham and started working at
what at the time was the biggest student
housing development uh called the
cottages of durm I rented out that
property and um then I went off on my
own since 2012 I've acquired my broker's
license and I currently manage about 250
Apartments 20 of which I own myself
the very first property I bought was a
small three-bedroom one bath ranch home
with an accessory dwelling unit in the
basement and I will never forget this
day because it was the day I was
familiarized with DM's code section
17556 which reads limitation on number
of unrelated occupants within the
following zoning districts any dwelling
unit consisting of an unrelated
household shall contain no more than
three unrelated
occupants and it goes on to list every
Zone in the
town what this means and what it was
designed for was to limit the number of
single family homes rented to groups of
friends bigger than three people homes
with say four or five bedrooms are not
allowed to be rented to any more than
three students because students are not
related even though they could
accommodate four or
five so let's pause for a second picture
me back in 2012 I just graduated at the
age of 23 I had my first job at the
housing developer
and I was netting around $2,100 a month
after taxes I just graduated college and
at the time at around $80,000 in student
loan debt and that monthly payment for
that debt was around
$1,100 my parents that same year moved
from Durham to a new place in Vermont
which meant I didn't have a place to
live which is why I bought that home
with an accessory dwelling unit in the
basement I took the only $14,000 I had
and I borrowed 500 from my father and I
got into a home that I was attempting to
house hack I was prepared to live in the
basement and hopefully eliminate my
housing cost so I could eat as food gas
and health insurance ate up the rest of
my available $1,000 a month at the time
bedrooms were renting believe it or not
for $600 a month after I bought the home
I was made aware of the fact that if I
lived in the basement I could only rent
to two of the bedrooms upstairs uh
because those people would be unrelated
to me so a third would mean I was out of
compliance
this meant that instead of getting
$1,800 a month I was only going to be
getting ,200 to put towards the mortgage
the result was I had to get an extra job
and put my student loan debt on hold to
grow even
bigger 10 years ago I had become
resigned to the fact that this is just
what it was Durham does not like
students and Property Owners subject to
this ordinance are just going to have to
deal that was until two years ago when
two things happened uh one of which I
think you'll hear from uh Fred Kell
who's here he's going to give you some
testimony um but the other was something
that happened to me I bought a
duplex and attached to the duplex was an
accessory
apartment
and um going into this acquisition I
knew that based on DM's legal
determination of this property I was not
allowed to rent the studio to someone
unless they were related uh to someone
in the primary unit what that meant was
the first year I simply just didn't rent
the accessory apartment I just rented
three individuals in the primary unit
and on the other side the second year
though I decided to rent the primary
unit to only two
people instead of three so I could rent
the studio at the same
time after I had that solved I rented
the studio went to rent the
three-bedroom on the other side um and I
still wasn't free and clear from this
unrelated ordinance because I went to
rent that three-bedroom I put an ad up
um I had a gentleman an international
student from Africa uh set up an
appointment the next week he came with
three of his
friends who are also International
students from Africa and like Diane had
just mentioned I had to tell them that I
couldn't rent the apartment to them and
it's too long of a story for here but I
was accused of a number of different
things um none of which were true I
actually did want to rent them my unit
but the town would not allow me to
those poor guys likely had to either
split up and pay more for a one or a
two-bedroom apartment or move to another
town outside of
durm and to have that be their first
experience in New Hampshire made me so
angry that's when I contacted Diane and
a bunch of students at UNH to support to
build support for a bill such as House
Bill
1281 so why does Durham and other towns
like Durham put this into effect effect
in the first
place I'd like to read um a gentleman's
statements from the online testimony it
was the only one who wrote in an
opposition of the bill his name was
Richard
Menny and he said excuse me uh sir yes
um if this testimony is online testimony
of somebody else we have already have
access to it we don't think we don't
need to reiterate it here we need to
hear your testimony not the testimony of
others okay thank you yeah I was just
giving it as to give you the perspective
of why they your testimony please okay
um so I won't quote him but um based on
Richard's statements sounds like he's
saying that if this doesn't go through
that we will I'm
sorry it's not his testimony we want to
hear your testimony on as to why you
think that this bill should go forward
sir
okay
I support this bill because
um what the opposite of it uh seeks to
solve is a noise trash and traffic issue
in these towns I have no issue with this
endeavor for clean and peaceful streets
every city should want this in durm
though it's a bit redundant because we
already have laws
supporting uh violations for noise and
trash as crazy it sounds uh their most
coherent reason for wanting to limit
students residing in neighborhoods is
their desire to limit car traffic and
reckless driving it's a legitimate
concern in my opinion though
implementing rules around cars linking
it to the unrelated ordinance has been a
desperate power grab for the town for
years seeing originally they didn't
address the cars as part of their
unrelated ordinance and since residents
have guessed with cars they found them
themselves in a new battle with
cars so what did they do over time they
drafted and voted on rules that limit
cars first they limited the number of
cars you could park within the 35 foot
front yard
setback then uh houses with longer
driveways were found to be able to park
more than that so they limited that
there's no more than three or four cars
the whole thing the whole
driveway then people had garages so they
could park more than three cars in the
driveway and the garage so they said
across the board no more than three cars
so that addresses another issue with the
cars so for example on this car issue uh
if you were a student living in a
three-bedroom house with no more than uh
uh sorry with two other roommates that
all Park their cars at your house if you
have a boyfriend or girlfriend that
wants to stay at their house a few
nights a week and park their car there
it isn't allowed because that would
appear to look like a fourth un related
person is living at the
property now if you hear the things that
I've said and maybe you're confused over
the last five minutes what is this guy
talk talking about maybe he's not
interpretating the zoning correctly what
the heck is he even talking about just
know that these are not my
interpretations they're the ones of the
town of
Durham and it is what they enforce and
the courts have backed them up as I can
attest
to we are also confused and bewildered
at the whole situation the lengths at
which the town goes to enforce this um
to
end I'd like to quote another person in
town
um that they acknowledge that what's
Central to this issue is the housing
Supply um and they admit that there is a
supply and that um the university has
decided to Force some people the
underclassmen to live on campus and
though that is true and that helps out
with it all the up all the upper
classmen that were going to live on
campus are now forced to live off so the
issue of the housing Supply is the main
part of this and simply put if we sign
this bill and if we enact this bill it
will immediately add back in housing
Supply units today with no construction
back into the dur market and that we all
can
agree will push rents down thank
you thank you for Testimony
representative y
Kell thank you thank you for uh your
testimony today um I have a couple of uh
or
clarifying uh a little bit of your uh
experience in the example that you gave
of the that first home that you bought
and there's three bedrooms and uh
accessory dwelling unit
um is it your understanding that the
regulations um would
not allow you to rent to um two
unmarried couples so if or is it is it
that you if the girlfriend or boyfriend
was staying over um but you didn't have
a contract with them to live there that
that would be allowed you can only have
like leases with these many unrelated
couples or they literally if you had uh
rented a room to two un unrelated people
and then their girlfriend started to
live with them uh that would put you out
of compliance even though you had
nothing you had no contract with those
those uh uh relationship that that is
kind of like spouse is
person so absolutely to unrelated ated
couples would be for unrelated people if
they weren't married and that would not
be allowed
um the situation that the the example
that you just gave of a boyfriend you
know spending or a girlfriend spending
too much time at the house is a great
example because if I only sign a lease
to three people the Town Administrator
the town code enforcer doesn't care
really if it looks like there's more
than three unrelated people living there
whether
it's cars that are registered to four
different families throughout the
country or if they have
a town code enforcement officer sit
outside your property and start trying
to determine who's related and who's not
they will pressure you and bring you to
court over the matter to figure it out
so that's how that
works representative
Holland so full disclosure I'm from
Durham I represent Durham and I was on
the Durham Town Council for 2016 to 2022
and have been part of the zoning that
has caused this um so I uh the reason
for the enactment and I'll get to the
question pretty quickly was uh nuisance
houses uh undergraduate houses
particularly in neighborhoods caused a
lot of problem and uh so my question to
you would be uh especially because you
mentioned the case uh would you be open
to saying that we would still allow the
three unrelated but we would wave it in
the case of one of the units was owner
occupied because again the owner
occupied in the unit would then help
with the reason that we did the three
unrelated which was the nuisance
requirement or the nuisance problem
sorry rep representative are you asking
if I've been in favor of that or not in
favor yeah would you I would I would not
be in
favor for the question actually to to go
further than that no sir no we don't go
back and forth everything comes through
the chair representative Brown
apologies okay so I'm I'm just trying to
get a comparison between what what's
trying to do with the law and what the
existing law allows you to do in a
maximum way so regardless of whether
they're related or not related you've
got a three-bedroom home with an
accessory drill
dwelling if they're related how many
people can you put in that home as many
as the house can accept per how it was
built
for bedrooms and septics and follow up
Mr chairman follow up
so as representative power said
typically homes are designed for two
occupants per bedroom so in your case it
would be six plus the ex accessory
dwelling so possibly eight is that
correct would you assume that I I would
assume that yes now
[Music]
um all the examples that I've given and
the only reason why this came up um
actually had nothing to do with double
occupied bedrooms double occupied
bedrooms are actually a fad that's going
away um to answer your question I think
from a while ago it was just to have a
reasonable cap on it so that there
wasn't a I only care about single alopi
ver in fact this build really was
intended only for that but we wanted to
put a cap on that so that there was some
reasonableness to it
anybody else have any
questions okay representative Brown you
can ask oh sorry representative you
Keller we'll get back to you
representative you had one more yes
thank you um so it has nothing to do
with Max maximum occupancy of a facil of
a building
right it has to do with from a technical
standpoint yes correct thank you yeah
representative
yell thank you um thank you for taking
another question
um kind of going back to my previous
question about um whether or not um we
should have uh any we we as a state
should allow any discrimination based on
familial status or
if um do you believe that that this uh
allowance for two occupants per bedroom
um based on familial status is okay or
do you think or would you support um uh
the state barring all uh familial status
discrimination and just rely on
occupancy load
essentially I think I understand that
question
um I don't particularly have a
preference on that because my motivation
from the beginning was just to be
allowed if I had a fourth bedroom and a
three bed and I could only rent a three
I just wanted the the person that is
willing to rent that single occupied
bedroom to be able to do it that's it
representative stavis thank you Mr chair
um this is a procedural question mainly
for you Mr chair which is um wondering
when we're asking questions of people
who are testifying if we could avoid
hypotheticals uh and instead just ask
factual questions about the bill at hand
I think that's an excellent point are
there any further questions for
this uh before you leave I have two sure
or maybe one um you mentioned the the
very first property you bought in
durm is am I correct that you found out
about the zoning regulations after you
purchased
it from what I recall it's it's yeah I
was I was made aware I should have been
made aware by my real estate agent at
the time but I I was not it was post it
was post okay did I also understand that
you knowing after that you knew the
regulations you bought additional
properties in the same town correct
thank
you all right any other questions seeing
none thank you for your testimony
representative Reed you are
up
prioritized
thank you Mr chair and thank you members
um I am a co-sponsor and am in support
of this bill for the record my name is
Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
which is New Market in newfields just
really quickly while I know there's a
lot of discussion around Durham my
neighboring Community um and I I got my
masters at
UNH um and and student housing and those
issues I want to kind of get back to the
general or origin of ordinances like
this one and it's not unique to New
Hampshire and those Origins are actually
kind of moral Authority religious based
um as in we don't want two unmarried
people in the same bedroom and I can
speak to that directly because when I
was a college student um I looked for an
apartment with my now husband but then
boyfriend we were about to sign the
papers we had looked at the place met
the land lady everything was great and
then she asked how long we had been
married and we told her we weren't
married and she immediately withdrew her
offer to rent to us claiming and I am
quoting that we would be living in sin
so um I don't think that that is the
role and I'll actually speak more to
this on a different bill of
municipalities to kind of morally um
restrict what people should be doing
you've heard all the reasons and we know
that we're in a major major housing
crisis and this is an easy way to
slightly alleviate that the issue that
got brought up is kind of Durham and the
um I guess the noise ordinance
violations or what have you that might
exist in a college Community I will say
that when people buy property in a
college Community they do know that they
are buying property in a college
Community also when you have uh noise
ordinance violations or other such
violations of kind of public behavior um
it's the job of the municipality to
enforce those ordinances not to kind of
preemptively just in case these crazy
kids get out of hand um restrict their
ability to live so having said that I
don't know if I can offer a lot of
technical assistance on the bill but I'm
happy to try to answer any questions
thank you any questions representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your
testimony uh besides the moral issue can
you tell me why towns Zone in this
manner I think you
heard a bit about um student housing and
uh the ordinances or the the the
noisiness of students or the perceived
noisiness of who might be students in
white towns would try to do that but um
as was stated if the house can safely
and technically house a certain number
of people I don't think we have any
business restricting that just because
we think somebody young might be a
troublemaker or whatever a follow up Mr
chairman follow up isn't it possible
that uh because of this bill you might
have those kind of situations but you
could end up with it slums in some
neighborhoods like a
condo I don't believe any more likely
than having uh six people who are
related in the same structure um again
we're bringing a lot of presuppositions
to who is moving in um it's it's kind of
silly it's the the idea that we can't
allow two people to be in the same
bedroom um who aren't already related is
is kind of silly especially in this
housing market and to say that they're
you know neru Wells um is really
prejudicial follow up Mr chair just
quickly would you st representative
Guthrie hold on we've got somebody else
who wants to speak I generally allow two
one followup your question so we'll come
back to you representative kahill okay
thank you thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question um it's my
understanding that
municipalities um hire like say their
number of law enforcement based on
population and things like that do you
do you think that suddenly changing the
ordinance and
increasing the potential population of s
Durham do you think that that might
cause an increased need for more cost
for the town by having to more law
enforcement so overall I would say no
and I don't think that there will be a
population explosion in the town of
Durham in particular and by the way for
full not only did I go to UNH and get my
masters there and I'm familiar um with
the situation I actually drove for
public transit all through dorham so
when people are talking about the
Cottages I know these places extremely
personally very well um the idea that if
they're college students they're going
to be bad people and we're going to have
to enforce it like I said I think that's
extremely prejudicial but in the case
where maybe there are increases of
incidents it's actually UNH has their
own police force to deal with
that further questions representative
you had one
more it was time sensitive Mr chairman
thank you okay very good all right see
no more questions thank you very
testimony uh next up we have Ben Frost
who said to minute so we're going to
hold you to that Mr
Frost not accounting for questions Mr
chair uh thank you Mr chairman and good
afternoon um I'm my name is Ben Frost
I'm the deputy executive director and
chief legal officer at New Hampshire
housing I'm here to speak in favor of
House Bill 1281 and I want to thank
representative power for introducing
this important
legislation uh what What's not apparent
in this bill is the implications of
federal
law the US Department of Housing and
Urban Development has standards
for uh landlord action that have
implications for municipalities as well
here in New
Hampshire uh there's law uh that dates
back actually to
1991 and this is a memo from the HUD
office of general counsel written by a
man by the name of Frank keading and it
establishes Hud's understanding of what
the um uh appropriate role is of
limiting the number of people per
bedroom and it is
a uh multiactor analysis as you would
anticipate from federal law uh that is
difficult to
interpret uh but basically what it says
to landlords and by extension also to
municipalities in adopting
regulations because you have to be
careful and thoughtful about adopting
maximum occupancy per bedroom
standards what this bill does is
establishes a baseline for
municipalities in New Hampshire that is
consistent with federal law there's
further analysis that should be done if
a municipality is considering limiting
occupancy per bedroom uh but this
establishes an important Baseline that
brings Municipal action in line with
federal law
um there there are a number of issues
that have been raised parking and and
and I agree that those can be addressed
and should be addressed through other
regulations septics septic systems are
based on Department of Environmental
Services standards based on bedrooms not
how many people occupy a structure but
on the number of bedrooms in a structure
you might have a three-bedroom house
with one person you might have a a
six-bedroom house with 12 people the
septic system is designed to accommodate
the flow coming from the bedrooms based
upon what de's understanding is of the
use of a structure and it's not based on
uh the number of people
there um I'll F note finally um the
question of marital status is a
protected class under New Hampshire law
so whether someone is married or not is
of no conc concern to a municipality in
its
regulations and is potentially a
violation of New Hampshire law for a
municipality to be so regulating it I
would make one recommendation on this
legislation and this gets to
representative y's earlier question on
lines eight and nine of the
bill there's language here that I think
unnecessarily limits the application of
the law if of this this legislation
where it says based upon the existence
of unrelated or non-familiar
relationships between occupants of such
rental property I believe that you can
strike that language and make this bill
even
stronger municipalities should not be in
the business of limiting people per
bedroom in a way that is inconsistent
with federal
law and this would achieve that I'd be
happy to take any questions thank you
for
Testimony representative yella thank you
thank you for taking the question
um it seemed in your testimony that you
that you uh stated that uh familial
status um is a protected class um in New
Hampshire
and that uh this legislation seems to
allow some discrimination based on
familial status um by municipalities
essentially um contradicting that
restriction based on uh discrimination
based on fonal status on on line eight
and nine where it says they can't do uh
less than two per bedroom so it seems
like they are allowed to do some
discrimination but you just said that
it's it's uh contrary to New Hampshire
law to be able to discriminate on
familial status so can you uh square
that Circle for me see if let me am am I
reading that
incorrectly I think he in his last
statement he addressed that
specifically his recommendation would be
to
eliminate line the the language on eight
and nine so I think that speaks exactly
to which you're asking was that his I
didn't understand that that his his
suggestion was to strike that whole
representative stavis it is thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question Mr Frost um you've introduced
uh marital status into the conversation
here I don't see that in this bill um
maybe I'm just not looking closely
enough but I see familial
relationships I do not believe that
familial relationships are protected
class so I'm wondering
where what is the basis for your
statement about marital status versus
what's in the bill which is familiar
relationships representative sis A
Familiar relation relationships are a
protected class and and that is the
basis for uh our laws against
discriminating against families with
children further question representative
Guthrie thank you for letting me get on
again Mr chairman uh what my concern is
that is that you got to have some kind
of
zoning if we didn't you imply that the
number of bedrooms did not impa act on
the septic system and it was unfair to
use them if if I read you right if
that's the case how about us using
bathrooms
instead as a matter of zoning
representative my my statement was that
um septic systems are designed based
upon the number of bedrooms what happens
if we use bathrooms instead is that a
better way we're getting off off to the
Weeds on that one that's bathrooms
versus bedrooms is not Rel to the
current bill I have to have some kind of
zoning Mr chairman thank you well that's
up to the zone at your town
representative priest and thank you for
taking my question and welcome Mr Frost
back to the
municipal again I go back to the issue
of parking since
I uh was an urban planner for 45 years
and I have seen residential
houses
um turn into to rental properties for
unlimited number of unrelated
people and I'm also aware of the housing
crisis that we are in and young people
who are having
to to share bedrooms and to live like
this because there's no housing
available I I get it um what I don't get
is how can we police the parking if a
house is in a residential single family
residential commun
neighborhood how can we police it to
make sure that they are not
impacting the rest of the
community thank you for that thoughtful
question representative PRI I I think my
my answer to your question is um well
has a couple of different aspects one uh
it's not really material whether
people are related uh as to the number
of vehicles and I think we can dispense
with that I know in my town there are
houses with many registered vehicles uh
parked in a yard uh and their single
family
homes um I think the qu the the my best
answer to your question is if you want
to regulate parking then regulate
parking and municipalities have the
authority to do so
don't do it by regulating the number of
people occupying a
bedroom it's good uh quick followup
representative uh so what you're
suggesting is that the communities um
say two parking spaces per
bedroom if if this bill was
passed we're
gonna no no more on the parking this one
doesn't speci unfortunately doesn't
specifically address that representative
further questions for represent uh for
Mr Frost seeing none thank you very much
for your teson uh next we have up uh
Fred Cal who's asked to speak for one
minute so we will'll ask you to do your
best to stay with that Mr Cal thank
you my name is Fred Kell I also own uh
rental properties in the SE coast of New
Hampshire uh this particular rule only
affects me in
Durham
um the I have many of the same same
experiences but I'll just give my own
personal just to keep it quick the code
enforcement officer watches my
properties very closely Audrey Klein and
her employees sit in their code
enforcement Vehicles outside my
properties every day they monitor every
vehicle that goes onto any one of my
properties they run the license plates
through the DMV figure out who owns each
vehicle whether it's a moped a
motorcycle a car anything with a license
plate um and this way they know anybody
that's at my properties at any time of
any day and this happens seven days a
week my properties are also inspected
four times per year during these
inspections Audrey counts the
toothbrushes in every bathroom to make
sure there's no more than three she
takes pictures of the shoes in every
bedroom to verify that they're all the
same size she goes through any mail that
she sees to make sure all the mail is
addressed to the tenants that live there
if there's a piece of mail from a
previous tenant that means there's more
than three people
on every inspection she tells me that I
should block off certain bedrooms so
that no one is quote tempted to live in
them every so often Audrey and the fire
inspector Brendan OS Sullivan will
trespass onto the properties knock on
the door and tell the tenant who answers
that he or she has no choice but to let
them inspect the property they typically
typically claim there's life safety
issues that they need to check on and if
the tenant says no Then they threaten
them with lawsuits and
fines they relish any opportunity to
tell my tenants how much control they
have over them Brendan has directly
called and text messaged some of my
tenants on numerous occasions to tell
them that he wants to inspect their
house without the landlord's
knowledge you're probably thinking that
I must have a whole lot of tenants and
durm for the town to devote this much
time effort and taxpayer money to spying
on them in reality I have five single
family homes that they focus on these
five properties have 22 bedrooms and
house a total of 15 people so a third of
my bedrooms are
vacant um While most cities and towns in
the area are finding the best way to
increase the number of available
bedrooms Durham continues to
deliberately limit its
Supply doesn't make a lot of sense in a
time where there's an ongoing housing
shortage three bed three people in a
five-bedroom house totally defies logic
and Common Sense most people that I've
talked to think that uh hb281 would
positively affect renters and Durham in
a number of
ways I'm in agreement and I know my
tenants would love the opportunity to
not have to live in fear of an
overbearing Town Administration that has
such a disdain for college students when
they live in a college
town um thanks for
listening thank you questions represent
K thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question do you think that
um UNH financially gains by being the
sole renter to the students by having
these ordinances in place in durh does
UNH gain
yeah um I think it's there's the same
amount of students regardless this is a
this is private property not un quick
followup
yet well what I mean is if they limit
your ability to rent to students by
making a third of your bedrooms unusable
through ordinance and then they are now
renting to the students who live on
campus I think their dorms are filled
already and this is just the excess
people who can't live in the dorms or
don't or don't want to and so there's
just the same amount of the same pool of
people are looking for housing and
they're just limiting how many people
can live in each property so it
basically creates a situation where
where you could have you know 10 people
living in three homes now 10 people can
live in fewer
homes
any other
questions thank you
sir okay we've got uh David
do David's asked for five
minutes I promise to be shorter than
that and I apologize uh for my bad
handwriting uh my name is Daniel du I'm
legal policy director at Pacific Legal
Foundation we are a nonprofit
organization um focused on separation of
powers um equality on opportunity and
most pertinent to to this committee um
property rights we um we've been around
for about 50 years now we've had 17 wins
at the US Supreme Court um we just
argued another case a couple weeks ago
and so we're very interested in this
issue we have a team that's dedicated at
looking at
um at housing issues because of the the
housing crisis but looking at it through
a a property rights um
lens
so we actually have a a federal lawsuit
right now um over this exact issue um
it's pending in Kansas the case is
called Home Room V uh city of shaune the
city has an ordinance limiting unrelated
occupants um just like this bill
contemplates it playes is
um uh it it uh we are uh representing a
business that facilitates roommate
relationships we're also representing um
a woman who um who out of the goodness
of her heart was allowing her her son's
uh girlfriend fiance to live with them
and they were unable to do so because of
of this ordinance we believe that these
ordinances uh violate constitutional
rights including the the right of
Association um and also discriminating
based off of familiar rights as uh or
familiar familial relationships as was
noted before um I'll just uh address a
couple of things that I think have have
been noted there's concern about whether
this is an attack on single family
zoning um I certainly don't think that
it is that um if somebody wants to build
an apartment building or a condominium
or something like that they still have
to get the permits to to build something
like that so this does not open the
floodgates for new building or
development or anything like this this
is for existing structures um and I
promise to be brief so with that I'll
answer any questions thank you very much
representative
majori thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um uh
hopefully hopefully this is in bounds
but you'll tell me if it's not I'm just
curious you said you your organization
has represented before The Supreme Court
before and I'm curious if if in that
experience you know whether or not the
Supreme Court has generally accepted
that municipalities can restrict the
number of unrelated people living in a
rental property uh through the chair
representative I think that there is
there is one case we don't think that
the appropriate um restrictions were or
or the appropriate claims were raised in
that case but um the Supreme Court did
not uh strike down that ordinance in
that case we think that the Supreme
Court it wrong and so we're trying to
litigate these things back up as you
know the the Supreme Court uh will
change precedent from from uh time again
thank for the question representative
Guth again thank you Mr chair and thank
you for your testimony particularly with
your background uh can you did you can
you tell us how uh a community would
protect the health and safety of people
living in say a condominium other than
uh some sort of zoning limiting the
number of people in that uh structure uh
through the chair representative uh this
does not to my understanding my reading
of the bill this do not a place a
limitation on uh municipalities to put
limits on number total numbers of people
parking uh septic any any of those kind
of things it's it's basic it's it's only
there to eliminate restrictions B based
off of familial
relationships all right um thank you
thank you very much I did if I may Mr
chairman I I I I misunderstood the bill
I thought it was more than that I
thought it was had an impact on zoning
and the number of people who who are
actually living in the structure thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony we have
Alysa
Margolis
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Alyssa margolin I
serve as director of housing action New
Hampshire um we're a Statewide
organization of 80 entities United to
improve state and federal policy so
everyone in New Hampshire has a place to
call home um we've worked with this
committee many times as you know um we
have a housing crisis in New Hampshire
and um it is probably it is it is the
number one issue uh of concern uh among
New Hampshire residents and is probably
the number one issue keeping our um
economic growth um we certainly have
Workforce shortages as a result um and
we have been partnering with um an
academic partner um St anom College uh
Center for ethics and society and they
uh took on um the New Hampshire zoning
Atlas and uh did um us all a great
service by presenting us with research
on the zoning barriers that were keeping
us from um developing the units that we
need uh in order to address the housing
crisis and um a lot of really important
discussions have resulted um since the
release of the atlas and one of them is
around reasonableness and so I ask the
committee to consider that I think
representative power um has a a great
example for for you to consider when
going outside of that health and safety
piece um and um and
uh likely with um motivations around
health and safety um but um but uh but
really
creating um unfair zoning barriers that
are keeping people from um enjoying the
their own communities and being able to
to grow and prosper in their own
backyards so we asked ask you uh to
consider the the balance of Interest
here and we think this would be a good
example of a of a time and a place to uh
to tell a community that they they
shouldn't have an ordinance in this
direction thank you and I'm happy to
take any
questions any questions from the
committee thank you Miss margolin thank
you chair M
turkot uh last pink card we have is uh
Jack
shner
did I get that one right you did thank
you good afternoon
Representatives I'll keep this short my
name is Jack shner I'm a 21-year-old
Junior studying agriculture at the
University of New Hampshire actually I
just rushed here from class I I am a
fifth generation farmer and no stranger
to hard work my values are slightly
different from my peers I don't
participate in any of the partying
typically associated with the college
experience I just work I'm I'm not one
of the noise
makers I just completed my third fall
semester with a 4.0 GPA working as a
handyman and other odd jobs to stay busy
between classes and returning to the
farm each
weekend this type of busy lifestyle is
the way I grew up and it makes me feel
accomplished however to my surprise and
maybe to yours uh despite how much time
I spend working it takes everything I
can muster to pay for basic expenses
each month like Fuel and food
in Durham my fellow students and I have
been subject to the exact Municipal
legislation that today's bill will
restrict my area of emphasis at UNH is
agricultural business I have taken
courses on economics and on real estate
it takes only a grasp of either to
understand that when Supply a market
decreases price increases I'm here today
to represent my peers in support in
support of House Bill 1281 which will
limit the exacerbation of already high
housing costs uh thank you for your your
time and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony are there any
questions seeing none thank you for
making the trip up here congratulations
on your 4.0 very
nice all right that was the last pink
card I have on HB
1218 uh 1281 was there anybody else
looking to speak seeing none I will
close the hearing on
HB 1281 and take about a two-minute
break and then we'll get into the next
one
girl
chair
okay
okay we're going to get
going uh we're going to open up the
hearing on HB
1250 and that is
enabling the creation of certain Village
districts I see the prime sponsor
representative wolf is sitting here
representative wolf you are
up thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the municipal and County
committee House Bill 1250 is a small
piece of legislation but a very big one
for the the ability to protect and
enhance the
environment house build 1250 adds one
additional purpose to the 14 that RSA 52
allows Municipal districts to have it is
the protection and Remediation of
surface water quality within a
district this bill allows for the
creation of one organization that has
the authority to create and enforce
rules that would protect protect water
bodies that exist in more than one
municipality in our case we're talking
about lake cipy that is four districts
four
towns as the multiple towns within a
district Watershed might have various
building
setbacks septic pumping rules erosion
Control ordinances and especially
varying enforcement it is necessary to
have one authority to protect the common
water body all of the water that is
within the Watershed needs to be treated
the same it all ends up in the same
place without a village District No
singular entity has responsibility for
water quality and Environmental
Protection passage of hb1 1250 would
have the ability to one give a mandate
to one legal entity to protect protect
the
Watershed provide consistent regulations
for the towns within the
Watershed provide consistent
enforcements of the rules and
regulations and number four offer the
ability to have prevention and planning
for the
future passage of this bill does not
form the village District it only gives
the towns within the district the
ability to vote to establish such a
District it is the first step but the
most necessary One to begin the
formation of a village District the 12
words that I referenced in my opening
statement could have a huge impact on
the future of multiple water bodies
within the state protection and
Remediation of surface water quality
within the
district this bill provides a framework
for towns to prevent Cal bacteria to
main maintain Pure Clean drinking water
and provide for the ability to have a
healthy Recreation and a clean
environment I'll be happy to answer any
questions on hb1 1250 thank you
representative wolf are there any
questions for the
representative representative FR yes
thank you uh Mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions uh question singular
can you uh enumerate the financial
considerations if any for the member
towns of a district if one were to be
formed again this is enabling
legislations the towns within the
Watershed district will have to get
together write their own um bylaws their
own operating regulations and then take
it to the voters of each of the towns so
I can't tell you what the financial
aspects would be um it's up to the
committee that will put it together and
then to the towns to vote and approve
this thank you for that response
appreciate
it further
questions I see none thank you very much
representative thank you very much
members of the
committee okay I have uh four pin cards
we'll start with Hal
krider
make sure you put on your microphone for
us please the right button just press it
down I have to keep pressing it if you
press the right one it will there you go
you're all set okay well thank you for
letting me speak uh I'm Hal krier I live
in Northwood New Hampshire I'm
here representing myself but I'm really
speaking from the experience that I've
had as a select board member for five
years chair for four
years I've been on the board and the
chair for our local municip excuse me
our local
local uh Watershed or Pond
Association uh so just recognize that
I'm speaking from my experience not as a
representative of those
organizations uh I think this bill is
important really from three perspectives
and they add to what the sponsor uh
mentioned um there's been a
downshift in spending the federal
government and the state government
aren't funding things for this type of
stuff for the prevention and treatment
of things like they used to it's harder
to get grants there's less money
available uh we need more certainty in
funding so we can take some of these
initiatives
on and the taxpayers and the local folks
want to see that it's a fair process so
in in terms of dealing with the
downshift in funding a lot of the things
like the lake host program are funded by
boat registration it's just not enough
uh on our association we spend 15 20 and
some years
$25,000 and we appreciate the money we
get from New Hampshire Lakes but it's
only like a couple thousand we have to
raise the
rest uh this would give us the means to
do that and I will say that in Northwood
we have four Village districts and they
work very well
uh they get consistency of funding and
all that type of stuff that goes with it
uh and why is that important well when
you go to hire somebody for the for the
lake host program it typically might be
a college student you'll talk to them in
January but you don't know if the town's
going to vote for funds to help support
that until March so they take another
job if you want to treat for example the
mil foil in in your water body you
actually need to get the permits 6
months before you even know if the
funding is available and
yes those folks around the lake will try
to raise some of the money but like in
Northwood they depended on $112,000 a
year from the town they wouldn't know if
they were going to get that till March
so that left them in this Catch 22 well
we we need to get you know the permits
we need to apply for the you know all
the treatment programs but we can't
confirm that because we don't know if
we'll get all the
money so there's that certain certainty
of funding that would really help
because you can depend on this much more
and then the third part of it is the
fairness issue in Northwood we're
fortunate the whole town supports the
environmental considerations so the town
via two different warrant
articles approves approximately 20 to
$225,000 a year now like I said with the
jennis pond
Association that helps that that gives
us another $4,000 but as I said it costs
us
20ish so again between the boat
registration that we get from Lake host
uh from excuse me Andrea and New
Hampshire lakes and the town we're only
covering a third of the cost and so we
try to raise it amongst all the other
folks around the the pond
well not everybody contributes so
there's a fairness issue there and then
you also got the fairness issue related
to you got folks that aren't even on the
lake saying well why should I support
this you know when people around the
lake aren't supporting it well as a
selectboard member I explained to them
that
well if the if the if the lake goes
south and you lose 20% of your value
your assessed value is you know going to
going to cause an increasing your tax
rate so they accept that and they do
support it but not to the extent that I
think they
would so those are the main reasons why
I think it's it's good legislation but
there's additional advantages that I
just want to point out and and that is
one as as the sponsor spoke and said
it's enabling legislation it's not a
mandate and people appreciate that they
don't like to be told you must do this
but if you approach them and say hey
here's something you know if we all vote
on it we can
do that
works um and it's a local funding effort
that we can control and put our effort
into uh and as I said before the current
Village districts that we have in in
North would really work very well and so
the idea that this could help us with
our Lakes is really important so I
really would appreciate if you you would
support this Bill thank
you thank you questions representative
stavis thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I don't have
any quibble with the substance of the
bill but my question has to do with the
words protection and
Remediation ah they're they're
vague yes I think purposely so I'm sorry
for interrupting yes but I mean who who
decides
what is protecting who decides what
remediation is
sufficient I think that's the beauty of
the bill it's part of the village
District they decide so just as an
example we have a village district for
water we have a a water tank we have a
water system it distributes it to
certain people that's their goal we have
a village District that has to deal with
road maintenance one of them only does
plowing one of them does plowing and
upgrades to the road so it's each
Village District that determines that
and for example in this case you might
have
some water bodies that are interested in
the lake host program and focus on that
you might have others that are worried
about cyano bacteria and the Watershed
as a whole they might focus on that I
know for sure Northwood lake is going to
focus on both because they have both
those
concerns for questions seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you uh we have Tom
Edwards and I always forget to remind if
you're giv testimony to speak if you're
I mean we kind of figure if you're in
favor or not but please do state that uh
we up here with the pink cards know what
you're doing the rest of the committee
and the audience does
not good afternoon my name is Tom
Edwards and uh I'm here to offer my
opinion on this bill I want to highlight
some of the issues that I describe in
more detail in the letter that is being
passed
around uh and also to make myself
available for questions at the end or
even later should you desire first know
that I am here representing only myself
but I want you to know that I am a I was
an officer of the puff Pond
Association um for 16 years I spent
eight as a secretary and most recently
the eight as its president so what I am
bringing to the party today is
experience that experience is what I
believe uh is perhaps missing uh in some
of these
testimonies I remain active in the
nonprofit corporation I do not have
knowledge of these issues but am by no
means an expert I do support the
proposed
legislation I believe that this
legislation will close some gaps that
currently exist for ensuring that New
Hampshire's over a thousand ponds and
lakes remain
attractive commercially robust and
recreationally viable it pains me to see
New Hampshire's Dees having to issue
ever more
cyanobacteria advisories and warnings
for our many pawns and lakes I have been
unable to find any of my Pawn side
Property Owners some who have been there
for many many years to recall any
incidents of the pawn having cob
Scio cyanobacteria pardon me prior to
the last few years none it didn't exist
this at least it was not noted this is
not not a good Trend here we need to get
ahead of this at our ponds and
lakes generally storm water runoff is
considered the primary suspect
triggering cyanobacteria
blooms and that is within the reach
where local M municipalities and
individuals can make a difference but
they need the
tools this bill can provide those tools
the ability of folks with interest in a
given Pond or lake cannot today use
their local knowledge of the pond or
lake to properly gather the data
necessary to effectively improve the
management of the quality of water in
their Pond or
lake uh business uh management 101 says
if you do not measure it you cannot
manage
it
municipalities with the aid of local
residents do not have access to either
the Authority or the tools to gather the
necessary data to even begin to
understand what
real what really is driving the issues
with water quality degradation in their
local body of
water they don't have the tools to
require Shoreland Property Owners to
determine let alone report on their
property concerning septic graywater
systems performance or storm water
runoff areas that could be contributing
to the well-being of the body of water
again this legislation can close that
Gap since this is enabling legislation
municipalities and locals do not who do
not wish to do anything can continue to
choose to do nothing and wait for
somebody else to solve the problem while
some communities will delay or even
scoff at doing anything this legislation
is aimed directly at those
municipalities
where there are resources just waiting
to be sprung into action by the addition
of this element to
52.1 this legislation will open up a
toolkit to a narrow group of
municipalities and individuals with
potentially having systemic impact on
the quality of our ponds and lakes which
we also
enjoy I encourage you to recommend that
this bill be passed into law thank you
any
questions thank you for thank you for
Testimony representative majori thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question which which may be better
suited for representative wolf and and
please tell me if it is you mentioned a
few words in there systemic problem and
in a toolbox I'm curious of the of the
village districts and and maybe
specifically you can answer this where
you have multiple districts on one body
of water where we may have to work on
how those districts are cooperating
together to be able to effectuate that
systemic Improvement that you're that
you refer to does that make any
sense it I suspect it does but for a
larger Pond I come from clu Pond I have
property on the shoreline for the last
18 years and the uh the pond itself is
44 acres and while we do cross town
boundaries we have just one piece of
property in Canterbury not in Lowden
that is on Shoreline but the extent of
some of the issues go beyond the actual
Shoreline itself as I pointed out in my
letter uh some of it is the based on the
landscape we have uh one side of the
pond has quite a section of Hills where
there's a lot of runoff and the property
owner that is on the shoreline is
disadvantaged trying to fix their runoff
because it's emanating from above them
further on the hill on the other side
we're much more flat and it doesn't go
as wide so a village District can
surround the pond with the relevant um
uh folks that are needed uh if this is a
large lake like a wiip pasak where there
are all different uh sections I don't
see how one could coordinate or would
want to from Meredith down to Walton
those are they got very different
problems at different ends of the lake
that would my perspective is very small
pwn thank
you further questions seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony thank
you next up we have Andrea
Laro good afternoon and and thank you um
chair and members of the committee I'm
Andrea Laro the president of New
Hampshire lakes and right now um being
passed around to is a letter of
testimony from New Hampshire lakes and
in support a letter of testimony from
the Lakes management advisory committee
in support and a letter of testimony in
support from the rivers management um
committee so New Hampshire Lakes were a
Statewide nonprofit organization with a
mission of restoring and preserving the
health of our Lakes and to build upon uh
what everyone else has said
already the the point I wanted to bring
out is that there are hundreds um of
Lake Associations local community groups
around the state that are working in
various levels with this New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services on
what are called Lake management plans
the state of New Hampshire does have
rules and laws and funding for Lake to
help restore and preserve the health of
our Lakes but it's not enough and the
beauty of of this is that we have again
hundreds of uh local groups that are
interested and willing to um help better
protect and restore Lake quality on the
landscape and they're just waiting for a
tool to do so um so with that I would be
happy to answer any
questions thank you for the testimony
anybody have questions on the
committee seeing none thank you for your
testimony perfect thank you one last
pink card if there's anybody else who
intended to speak make
sure you
have filled out a pink
card and the last person we have is
Steph
Miller I'm kidding Jack cutner you're
up
how was a good
one oh it's already on thank you my name
is Jack cutner I am in Newberry which is
on Lake
sunap um my perspective is a little
different from some of the earlier
testimony because in fact I see this
legislation um as a way to enable better
ACC
on a large lake where there are multiple
municipalities that are jointly
responsible um for the quality of the
Watershed um my experience is as
follows Lake sop protective Association
in 2020 completed an extensive study on
water quality on lake stie and Lake stie
while relatively pristine
is like all water bodies in New
Hampshire water quality is is on the is
on decline in Decline and the reason for
that is is rather simple a as more and
more development happens around the lake
within the Watershed there's a finite
amount that the Lakes can
absorb as construction occurs there's
more and more runoff more and more
septics septic fail failure Road salts
Etc it
is interesting when you decide to take
on the Clause with the local communities
to say we need to be more proactive what
you quickly realize is no one is
responsible for water quality within the
Sunapee Watershed why do I say that
because everybody is responsible and
when everybody's responsible nobody is
responsible what representative Wolf's
legislation would do was create a is
create a framework where the towns would
agree to participate and cooperate to
create a single set of rules and a
single set of authority to
get protective action in place for Lake
cipe this obviously could become a model
for other large Lakes um seano bacteria
is an epidemic problem chloride in the
lake is accumulating slowly because of
Road
salts many of the towns don't have
septic regulations in place septic tanks
are failing and leaking into the water
table and into the lake and as you go
from town to town you find every set of
zoning requirements is different
enforcement is spotty or non existent
and this would be an uh uh an
empowerment to try and get in front of
the protection that's needed for really
what is New Hampshire's arguably
greatest natural resource which is which
is our Lakes thank you for listening
I'll take
questions thank you for Testimony
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you all right seeing no more
pink cards uh we uh we did have a blue
sheet on it not sure where that
went there was a number of individuals
signing off in
favor looks like six in favor so with
that we will go ahead and close the
hearing public hearing on HB
hi
Laura okay we're down to the last bill
of the day we're going to go ahead and
open up HB uh hearing on hb1 1297
relative to the authority of
municipalities to enforce
ordinances uh Prime sponsor Ellen Reed
you are up thank you once again Mr chair
and thank you again members of the
committee again and for the record my
name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 new market and new Fields
um so before you was a little bit of an
idea that I had as a kind of
compromise um you are likely aware as
the municipal committee that not just in
this state but actually Nationwide as we
are experiencing
increasing uh demand in in and
increasing suffering in the housing
crisis that one of the trends how I say
Trends one of the resorts that people
are taking is to undo some of the
exclusionary zoning that towns have
historically done so I want to bring up
um and I and there's two pieces to this
in terms of ordinances and so just
permit me to get there but I want to go
into a little bit of history in 1926
there was a supreme court Federal
Supreme Court decision which you may be
aware of called uclid V amly company
that decision was essentially the
decision was that the ability for
municipalities to have police power
valid police power in other words for
them to uh pass ordinances that have uh
legal Authority is based on public
health and safety in other words there
is no constitutional guarantee and it's
probably unlikely that municipalities
have the Constitutional ability to pass
ordinances that are not based on public
health and safety and yet and two years
later in 1928 the New Hampshire Supreme
Court decided very similarly in the case
sundine versus Rogers um specifically
there there was uh the question of
whether or not a town could restrict
whether or not an auxiliary building
like a barn or garage could be in the
front or had to be in the rear of a
property and the court um decided that
if it was for the appropriate usage of
light air to to reduce the risk of fires
or to reduce the risk of auto accidents
then a town could restricted but not
necessarily for aesthetic purposes so
that was our Supreme Court decision two
years after the uclid decision and they
basically backed up what the federal
courts had said around that time is when
um redlining became a thing and so
zoning ordinances were increasingly used
to keep certain types of people uh
people who were considered to be
undesirable by the people who were in
charge of towns out of those towns or
restrict them out of certain areas of
those Towns now while we may not have
technical redlining anymore what we do
have is still to this day um the very
clear effort to keep certain types of
people and it may be not based on race
anymore but it's definitely at a very
bare minimum based on economic
strata so um let me just read from uid
that's the federal Supreme Court case
municipalities have the power to
regulate the height of buildings area of
occupation strength of building
materials and I'm going to condense this
um in the interest of Public Safety and
Health however we believe it however to
be the law that these Powers must be
reasonably exercised and that a
municipality may not under the guise of
the police power arbitrarily divert
property from its appropriate and most
economical use or diminish its value by
imposing restrictions which have no
other basis than the momentary Taste of
the public
authorities
nor can police regulations be used to
affect the arbitrary desire to have a
municipality resist the operation of
economic laws and remain rural exclusive
and aesthetic when its land is needed to
be otherwise developed by the larger
public good and public welfare I think
making sure that everyone has a place to
live in this state is certainly
qualifies as the public good and public
welfare
so having said that the first part of
this kind of compromise I came up with
is saying that those residential
ordinances by the way just specifically
residential ordinances cannot be passed
if they are not directly tied to the
best scientific understanding in the
moment of health and safety of the
residents that means that as technology
is improving or as more Technologies are
available as long as those Technologies
meet federal and state requirements for
health and safety that the town can't
restricted so this is things like tiny
homes if the tiny home meets federal and
state requirements the town should not
be able to restrict it because the town
can only restrict on the basis of health
and safety
um quanite homes prefabricated homes uh
certain septic Technologies Energy
Technologies water Technologies these
are all becoming more and more available
however towns seem to be kind of stuck
in the past when it comes to what they
will allow and it's getting to the point
that we're in a housing crisis we have
no option but to get creative and if
those technologies that exist now we're
not saying people should be allowed to
like build Huts but if the technology is
good and the FEDS say it's good and the
state says it's good and the town has no
health and safety scientifically founded
health and safety reason to prohibit it
then we should not be prohibiting it so
that's the first part the second part of
this is kind of almost the inverse
because we are in a Dylan's rule state I
actually uh Prime sponsored two attempts
for a constitutional amendment to give
towns the authority to pass rights-based
ordinances to protect health and safety
of their residents
this is a much smaller version of those
Constitutional Amendments that I
attempted but this essentially enabling
legislation that we enable towns to also
pass ordinances when it comes to
commercial activity that would harm the
health and safety of their residents so
not say we don't like that the look of
that warehouse so we're not going to
allow that company that wouldn't be okay
but what would be okay is you can't have
that posos company putting chemicals in
our River or you can't in very famously
in our area since we were talking about
Durham Lee very famously 15ish years ago
had USA Springs come in and uh try to
take all of their water and the problem
is is that the entity that's in charge
of whether or not that's allowed is Dees
but Dees acts as a rubber stamp as a way
to help approve these projects and the
local people who it impacts have no
ability to stop those projects
even if it directly harms their health
and safety so this is enabling towns to
pass ordinances that they have not
previously been able to to protect
health and safety from certain dangerous
commercial activity and it's also saying
you can't pass residential ordinances if
it's not for health and safety um I
thought this was a good compromise uh
officials in municipalities not all but
some the ones perhaps more influential
in the municipal Association probably
didn't agree but you know what they say
about compromises um you know you've
done a good job if everybody walks away
unhappy
so I did want to read one last piece of
uid because this is an example in every
ordered Society the state must act as an
Umpire and this is going to the the
commercial the ability to have
ordinances on basis of health and safety
against certain dangerous commercial
activity in every order ordered Society
the state must act as an Umpire to the
extent of preventing one man from so
using his property or rights as to
prevent others from making uh from
making a correspondingly full and free
use of their property and rights the
abstract right of a man to build a fire
trap is limited by the rights of other
people not to have their houses
subjected to the Peril by it the right
of a man to maintain a nuisance on his
own property is limited by the right of
others to not be subjected to the danger
of its proximity accordingly the
so-called police pow is an inherent
right on the part of the public umpire
to prevent misuses of property or rights
which impair health or safety so once
again towns have the Constitutional
ability to pass ordinances for health
and safety but even as they're saying
that it's on the basis of we're allowing
we C we can prohibit activity that takes
away other people's rights but we can't
prohibit activ
beyond that and that is actually called
the Lafayette principle that we should
govern only in so far as we we remove
rights that take away other people's
rights you have the right to do anything
except take away other people's rights
um so that's the the gist of it and I I
just really wanted to have this
conversation because I think we've run
really far field of the original uh 1926
Supreme Court UK decision as well as the
28 Sund Dean Rogers decision um where we
are supposed to be primarily and only
exclusively making sure people's health
and safety is taken care of and I'm
happy to answer
questions representative
power thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
representative so if my contacts are
working properly at this time of day so
this is all brand new section that
you're
adding and it says to amend 674 by
inserting
after section 76 but why on line four is
it numbered
67476 shouldn't be colon
77 I believe it was not that long ago
that the answer to a similar question
was this language was drafted by an
attorney in OS who specializes is a
municipal law and so while that may be a
mistake I would have to ask that
particular attorney if that is a mistake
or
not followup follow up go ahead um so
I'm I'm looking at the statute right now
in in statute we have section 674 colon
76 religious use of land and
structures so I think that there's a not
intending to overwrite the existing
legis ation or existing law rather and I
appreciate the
correction further further questions
represent uh
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I was curious
about line
15 um where we don't apply this to
commercial structures and Commercial
zones that's that's fine and the multif
family structure units but why
subdivisions why doesn't it apply to
subdivisions because as I so again I
actually was trying to get a compromise
with the municipal Association so I
wanted to limit it as much as possible
subdivisions kind of being their own
thing and being allowed based on what
they've already planned um that is why I
separated them out but if the committee
so felt the need to expand it and remove
the limitation from subdivisions and I
would certainly support
that for the question representative
Gallagher um so the principal you were
citing the lafette principal um would
you consider that to be essentially
equivalent to uh John Stewart Mills harm
principle if you're familiar with that I
am familiar with it from college which
was 20 years ago but yes my
understanding is is very
similar represent majori thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question represent resentative in uh I
apologize my my copy doesn't have the
line numbers on it but in section one
the last sentence says that the
ordinance must provide written findings
of fact and my question is uh the best
current scientific evidence relied upon
by the legislative body um could it
could could that be amended to say the
the local land use board because as a
planning board person we we would go out
for expert uh findings we would go out
for that kind of research but I would
never ask the legislative body to direct
us to find the best current research do
you mean your SE your select board the
legislative body of the town or of I I
don't read this to mean the state house
if that's what you're asking no I Mr
chair may I clarify uh and and it could
be that I have it totally wrong when I
see legislative body I think the
legislative body of my town Northampton
going to Warrant to ask the legislative
body to direct the the and I'll say
planning board to find that local
evidence I'm just curious if if that
could be tightened up to
say a a local land use board or a
planning board because that's who would
be going out to get that research I
would be very happy to um amend it as
you suggest it makes
sense for the
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony we have one more pink card and
that is representative U not
representative fellow
chairman thank you Mr chair members of
the committee I'm Philip Sherman chair
of the building code review board I
oppose this uh but only on a matter of
clarity uh this issue comes up because
many of the municipal actions on related
to building codes still travel through
the land use sections you may hear more
about that next year if we can ever find
the bottom of the pile um so the bill is
unclear as at least as I read it as to
whether it's intended to apply to only
zoning and planning type ordinances or
all land use ordinances which can
include some amendments to the building
code for instance is the prohibition on
housing ordinances involving energy
intended to prohibit local amendments to
the State Building Code involving the
energy code and so on with some of the
other issues
um so I respectfully suggest that this
bill be amended somehow to clearly State
whether the intent is to permit
amendments to the building code that
impact housing in either a positive or
negative light uh and I'm happy to work
with anybody who wants to to talk about
the wording on that I'm willing to
answer any questions at this point thank
you for your testimony are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you I don't have any more pin
cards I have had one uh nhma signed in
against I don't see anybody here from NH
at the moment so with that we will go
ahead and close the hearing on HB
1297 that is the end of our agenda for
today
um should be in the calendar going out
I'm not sure if it's been sent to the
entire committee yet for next week on
Tuesday we will be meeting it has been
sent out we have a number of bills then
and I
believe that was uh check the calendar
to be sure I believe that meeting is
going to start at 9:30 rather than 10
that's just because of the bills that we
have I don't want uh I don't want to run
out of time so we're going to start at
9:30 next Tuesday all right questions
seeing none have a good
weekend